Ladies and gentlemen,
this,
this is unsuspecting.
This unsuspecting,
unexpected is the word I was looking for was searching.
I'm not good when I get up before noon.
Dude.
I know it doesn't work for me.
I made too.
Did you see Emma?
Yes.
It helps you sleep,
right?
Yeah,
but it makes it kind of groggy for the first hour or so was pretty groggy.
Gives me hard morning.
Boners yeah,
I find that it really increases my morning wood.
Yeah.
The Joe Rogan experience podcast is sneaking up on bitches.
See,
I'm looking right now.
There's hundreds of people that are alive.
How the fuck did they know this content?
I'm not calling you cuts.
I love it.
They're Ninjas.
I love Ya.
But you ninjas,
you fucking snuck in all 277 of you.
We didn't tell anybody what time we're doing this.
Maybe I told maybe I said like 1230.
And so people just kept their browsers open.
Did you?
I don't know.
I'm sneaky like that.
Yesterday was a big blur.
Yeah.
Yesterday,
Brian put together the,
uh,
all the equipment we had all,
well,
let's just fucking do the commercial real quick.
The Joe Rogan experience podcast is sponsored by this episode,
at least,
is sponsored by audible.com and a audible has a really fucking bad ass new
application called audible,
I believe it's called audible whisper sync.
Yeah.
Whisper.
I don't get it.
Well,
tell me,
explain that isn't beautiful.
The idea is with a,
and they sent me one of those kindle fires,
which I've yet to a fire up.
I have the regular kindle,
the one that looks like paper.
It's really pretty cool.
I got a new one.
I actually have two.
I have three of them now because I have the paper one,
but they sent me the fire HD,
which works on Amazon.
It allows you to get movies and,
and what,
what this,
this,
the application that audible has that's native to it or it's built in rather
comes with the,
uh,
the kit,
the kindle fire.
It's really amazing.
What it is,
is you read the book,
like say if you're at home when you're reading the book and you're like,
oh,
I got to get to sleep.
And when you get up in the morning,
you sink the page to your smart phone.
So when you get up in the morning,
you plug your smart phone in your car and a companion audible book picks up
where you left off.
So it's a professional audio book with like a real actor reading it.
Don't ever get the ones with Stephen King reading his own shit.
Really see if in case one of my favorite authors,
don't get me wrong,
but it's way better when you have like an actor reading yet he's like sort of
flat with his,
his delivery,
but it's writing him up the stairs and we got shy.
He tries,
it's just awkward.
It's awkward,
but he's a fucking brilliant writer.
But it's the audible books with him Kinda of socket.
But um,
I just love that this,
I think this is the future and it,
it makes to me it makes commutes so much better.
I drove over here.
I was listening to an audible book.
Uh,
um,
I,
I think that it,
it's,
uh,
it's a great way to make time if you live in any sort of situation,
we have to travel.
You have commuting air,
whether it's airplanes or whether it's,
uh,
being stuck in traffic every day.
Uh,
an audible book really makes the difference between fucking hating it and
actually enjoying your time.
Um,
and,
uh,
the way,
audible has set up.
They have,
I mean,
I don't know how many fucking thousands of different audio books available,
including Steve Martin's,
which is a really cool cause.
Born standing up is actually read by Steve Martin,
which is awesome to hear him tell his story of his own life.
It's,
it's really,
and as a comedian,
that one really is,
I'm very motivational to like,
you listen to Steve Martin talk about like the glory days and starting out in
common.
It makes you want to go on stage.
Starting up here at the ice house,
he talks about the ice house alive.
Yeah.
Well this place is fucking super duper historic.
Um,
if you go to audible.com Joe,
um,
audible,
we'll give you 30 days free service and they will also give you a,
um,
one free audio book.
So go and check it out.
You'd try it free for 30 days.
It's an awesome service.
They're really cool company.
They've been around a long time and uh,
they've supported a lot of comedians to like a,
I was talking about with proofs the other day.
I know he did some stuff for them and Marmel did some stuff for them.
And it's,
um,
just a,
a really a cool and useful product that I think that if you haven't been into
audio books before,
it will really enhance your life,
especially if you're any sort of commuting city in Eddie sort of commuting
situation.
So go check it out.
You dirty bitches.
And um,
we were also sponsored by [inaudible] Dot Com uh,
on,
it has expanded if you haven't been there in a long time.
We started out as essentially just a supplement company and we've worked our way
into fitness equipment.
We now sell a Blendtec blenders,
which,
you know,
I'm always talking about a drinking Kale smoothies and Kale shakes make you,
it's just a massive amount of nutrients that are really makes your body feel
fantastic.
Um,
so we started selling the blenders to make those things.
So we started selling Blendtec blenders.
Uh,
um,
I'm a big fan of kettle bells and battle ropes and,
and doing things and exercises which enhance what's called functional strength,
meaning strength that you can use,
uh,
you know,
in an athletic endeavor,
picking things up,
strength that really comes into play instead of like,
there's a lot of like bodybuilding type exercises that just really make you look
sexy as fuck,
but they don't do anything.
Um,
they don't really enhance your athleticism.
They,
they,
they enhance your ability to move things in an isolated manner,
which is kind of unnatural.
The way you pick up things really is you use your entire body when you're,
you know,
you're moving things around and carrying things.
You're using all your muscles together and coordination as one.
That's what kettle bells are all about.
Uh,
it's my favorite form of exercise as far as weight training.
I think you can get everything in there.
You need your strength training in there.
He can get conditioning and cardio with weights,
uh,
with kettle bells.
And we even sell a,
one of my all time favorite videos for watching,
uh,
for,
for training with kettlebells.
Um,
it's the Kettlebell cardio workout by,
uh,
Keith Webber,
extreme kettlebell cardio workout and uh,
it's a fucking,
it's out of stock.
We sold them out already.
They're that good man.
They're fucking tremendous.
They're there.
It's,
it's,
it's one of my favorite all time videos.
He just puts you through the fucking meat grinder and I do it with a 35 pound
cattle bouts,
not much weight.
You'd think you could do that all day long.
You can't,
it's fucking brutal.
And it's an amazing cardio workout like that.
It's one of the best as far as I'm doing something for me that translates to
Jujitsu.
This,
uh,
this workout is one of the best.
And so all that shit,
we have it on it,
the supplements,
all of them come with a first order of 30 pills,
100% money back guarantee.
You don't have to return the product.
Just no one's trying to sell you anything.
This sucks.
It's all good stuff.
It's not going to fix you,
but if you want to make your life better,
one of the best ways to make your life better is to have a body that works
better,
whether it's through exercise and most certainly through nutrition.
Um,
I'm a huge proponent of eating healthy,
of taking a lot of green leafy vegetables,
eating vitamin supplements.
I took a lot of vitamin supplements every day.
I take these a athlete,
pure pack,
so everything's all packed up for me.
Um,
and I take an extra fish oil and I took a lot of different,
um,
uh,
honored supplements like Alpha brain before shows and shroom tech sport before
workouts.
Just too much dimension.
So go,
I'll check it all out on a.com.
And if you use the code name Rogan,
you save 10% off any and all supplements,
right?
You dirty freaks.
Cue The music,
Brian.
Let's make an official
the Joe Rogan experience.
Try my day.
Joe Rogan podcast my night.
So Ladies and gentlemen,
as of right now,
as of this moment,
it's just me and my little buddy Brian.
What's up?
Fell.
We don't do enough of these anymore.
I know.
I uh,
had a really rough night last night.
What happened?
I,
uh,
took the Zma and then I went out to eat and I started falling asleep while I was
on the beginning stages of Zma and that stuff hits you hard.
Like I couldn't really drive on the way home.
It was like being drunk driving lesson.
Yeah.
So don't drink or don't Zma before you drive and then go to Denny's.
Denny's.
I can't wait a minute.
But zinc is just,
it means Zma rather is just zinc.
Magnesium.
And what else?
Is there anything else in there?
A couple of sleeping pills.
So it's a matter that to me,
it doesn't do that to me at all.
It was,
it was,
I was seeing double.
I did the pirate drive where you had to hold,
have to hold when I,
while you drive,
you know this.
It's weird how weird people's bodies react to different things.
Like people that are allergic to peanuts.
I know it's true,
but I don't believe it.
Like I know it's true,
but I want to like eat that peanut bitch.
You know you can eat that peanut Kimmy though,
so I'll eat them.
This is nothing wrong with peanuts,
woody.
I could that be possible.
We did at a restaurant where a lady eight something,
I don't know if it was peanuts or some kind of fish or were her throat started
getting closed up in the ambulance.
Had to take her away.
Will that happen to a guy on fear?
We didn't know
that he was allergic to eating roaches.
Right.
By the way,
there was a roach eating contest and Florida and the guy fucking choke to death
and died.
Same reason.
Was it the same reason?
Yeah,
I think isn't it?
Because if you're allergic to a shelter,
well that's what it was on fear factor.
But I don't know about this row cheating guy who died eating guy dies.
Roaches.
Have you ever lived in a house that had roaches?
Oh yeah,
definitely.
And the east coast.
It's real problem.
Sometime much of a problem in the in La and not as much of a problem they have
from out here.
Like I saw a big one out here in Pasadena at the icehouse fucking giant one
who's probably alive back when Dean Martin was still with Jerry Lewis
fucking roach was you like Disney writes is they don't even,
they seem drawn the,
the,
the w we have a rat problem at my house,
like just tons of mice and rats.
They don't go in the house,
but they just all live in trees.
Like my tree is,
has like two rats.
They're just living up there like fucking kids in a tree house.
This guy choked to death on his own vomit.
Oh,
whoops.
Says Edward Archibald choke to death on his own vomit after downing piles of
bugs at a pet store.
Contest it Pat's store,
how to fucking row cheating contest.
And this guy has a giant mouth full of roaches and he choked to death on his own
vomit.
Wow.
That's weird way to die man.
Cause he Roche Pharma,
Ilo has legs and it's half of it's moving.
I can't help but feel a little bit responsible for this I think.
Oh yeah.
You're somewhat involved.
Yeah.
I think I contributed to this part of the retarded culture.
No,
by through fear factor.
I think I definitely contributed to this,
at least part of this.
It's craziness.
Jesus Christ.
That's is just serving thing to read man.
Choke to death on his own vomit during a cockroach eating contest at a pet
store.
Fuck man.
It really is like running man.
Like when you watched the movie running man,
they show you like people going for money and dogs chased him and biting them
and be like,
well that would never happen.
This is just an exaggeration,
but the more you see shit like that,
he was not really an exaggeration anymore.
In fact,
it's just as fucked up or more fucked up than fiction than fiction.
Like the come drinking part in fear factor when we had people drink com that's
more fucked up than anything you've ever seen in a movie about life being fucked
up.
And it was real.
You know when you have like a movie,
when they have those scenes of like crazy crazy shows all yeah,
like parody things.
Yeah,
it's fucking disgusting.
Um,
your,
uh,
your Roden problem,
they have a unique way of trying to solve that.
In Chicago.
In Chicago,
they have coyotes that they know where the coyotes are,
they know their nests there in Chicago there's 60 of them and these coyotes are
tracked.
They have collars on them with like RFID devices or whatever the fuck it is.
They use to track them and they follow them around to make sure that,
you know,
these coyotes are like
killing all the rats.
Why don't they just,
that seems dangerous that Lou just released coyotes.
I mean,
they're not dangerous animals really,
but yet they kill animals.
Why don't they just released tons of cats?
All the cats that are in the,
in the,
like the pins or whatever.
I think it's shelters,
first of all,
cause I think people associate cats with pets.
You know the associated with Aw,
poor little kid.
He'd come to my house and you keep them in your house and then the fucking cat
doesn't get to eat the rats.
And the other thing is that they spread diseases like that toxoplasma thing,
the one that they know about with rats,
there'll be really irresponsible if you want it to have a bunch of cats and a
bunch of rats interacting with people.
What if they put give him little outfits.
It shows that they work for the city,
like go orange like outfits and stuff and you're like,
it's illegal if you take them into your house,
people would take them in any way.
Joey d is this cock saga.
He didn't sign up to be working for a fucking DEA over here.
This little guy,
this little buddy,
he's mellow pal.
He ran a fucking chicken littles.
So he gives a tender vittles put trackers just like the coyote pit,
Lowell fitbit's and the cat's acids.
I don't know
that works like that.
I don't think if you do that to cats,
people will get mad at you.
If you had a bunch of cats run around with RFID collars on and you were leaving
them in the wild and forcing them to fend for themselves,
but you tell them like,
hey,
or they're going to get euthanized tonight.
Yeah.
But people would want to feed them.
They would want to be interacting with them.
And when people interact with cats,
if it's a feral cat,
that's when you have the risk of that toxoplasma infection.
So I think it would be,
yeah,
but that's why you just have to make it,
I have a little costume and make it illegal.
Like,
look,
you get three years of jail.
We have trackers and he,
these are working cats.
Maybe put a little nights in their hands or something like that.
So you can't touch him.
I don't think.
I don't think that,
um,
I think Kylie's are better at killing anyway.
Yeah,
I think they're better at it.
You know,
coyotes are creepy fucks.
Just seems like we have would have more cats to get rid of or they're going to
eat the cat.
Cody's going to eat the cat stuff.
They're going to Andrew's,
well the definitely dangerous,
but if they only have 60 of them and they uh,
they keep an eye on,
it's a novel idea.
They know where their dens are and everything.
That's crazy.
It's fucking beyond crazy.
I mean,
they have a,
essentially of these wild predators,
just small enough to be manageable.
It's not like a team of polar bears.
It lives in your town.
They're just small enough and they're just hungry enough to keep the rat problem
in check.
Fucking my work dude.
They're testing out drones.
That's drone training.
Yeah.
It's like a drone.
You're right.
Coyotes second animal drone.
Yeah.
We,
yeah.
And how do we know that?
Did Not fucking putting chips in those coyotes brains.
Yeah.
Those are Google coyotes.
Remote controlling.
I'm from Florida.
Could be coyote.
Got Mail.
Yeah.
Coyotes are a,
that's a creepy thing to have around children too,
because they will kill a kid.
Yeah.
Well I think cats won't kill,
kill,
kill a kid.
And you just like the whole,
the whole city has tons of cats everywhere.
There's not going to be any mice.
And then yeah,
that's what they do.
If the,
if the,
the coyotes do keep the
rat population in check to the point where there's no more rats.
And how do they get access to the rats?
How do you ensure that the coyote is get access to the rats?
It's almost like you have to bait the rats.
Like how do you get them into like a,
a spot where the car,
he just like let the coyotes figured it out.
Figured out.
The problem is the county is going to be shy of going near people.
So you're going to be crass,
but the rats are going to be near people cause that's what the garbages so if
the coyotes go near the rats,
they're going here,
the people.
So the coyote is going to be around people.
That's creepy.
And it only takes a couple months till we start fucking those coyotes.
And can't you?
No,
not,
not.
Well,
if it was held down,
tied to,
tried to kill you,
would you fuck it?
Uh,
if I had to like poodle,
you mother fucker just took your deck in the coyote.
I'm not for dominate them.
Yeah.
Animal Sex.
It doesn't seem as good as like fish stacks and dolphin fish and dolphins fish.
Well,
fish sex just don't have sex.
It seems cleaner and slang.
They don't even have vaginas.
Do you know that fish?
They don't sex.
Yeah,
but they have very big bow.
The mail.
They're big mouths.
Yeah.
With teeth in them.
Do they have teeth on their tongue?
Yeah.
You just pull out the teeth and fuck it.
I don't think you can pull out tongue teeth.
Oh,
have you ever that I've ever seen that fish where um,
there's a parasite that lives inside of its mouth and eats its tongue and
actually replaces its time and it becomes the tongue.
Yeah,
it is the tongue.
Like cautious mouth.
I Dunno,
it just Google fish with a parasite for tongue,
but it literally doesn't have a tongue anymore.
It has this fucking bug living in its mouth.
Nature you scary need to use.
So scary.
One of the newest things that someone tweeted me is this a combination polar
bear,
grizzly bear hybrid that has been seen a lot in Alaska lately.
The tongue,
the tongue is nuts.
Hey guys,
how are you doing this with the picture we're looking at is a dead fish that has
this larva.
Whatever the fuck it is.
Beetle bug looking thing.
Look living in its mouth that literally replaces the fishes tongue,
takes a spot.
The fish can't get rid of it,
so it just accepts the fact this thing lives in its mouth and the fish keeps
eating and as the fish is eating this,
uh,
this thing living as its tongue gets to feast.
This works the Dick and this works the balls.
It takes the same place.
Like it helps get the food down into the hole,
but it also steals a bunch for itself.
I guess.
That's crazy.
The parasite relationship with parasites and organisms is so creepy.
There's so many different weird examples of parasitic relationships.
I been calling your phone,
Bro.
Oh,
they really look at this picture.
This is like a skeleton version of that parent's site animal thing.
Oh,
that was,
that was that dude.
Ooh.
See,
fuck.
Oh,
hey.
How's it going?
Big Guy.
I don't know if I call them back.
Let me see if I can,
I'm going to kiss it.
You want me to kiss it right now?
Um,
yeah.
The parasitic relationship.
It's a very strange man.
Parasites.
That's a good question.
I have what's inside there?
Hey John,
it's Joe.
Did you get the other number?
Okay.
It's been busy.
That number's busy.
Okay.
It's still busy.
He's saying.
All right.
Hold on one.
We're,
we're,
we're uh,
we're gonna make sure it's cleared off right now.
Otherwise,
I'll just put you on speaker phone.
Yeah,
let me,
let me hold onto you for a second.
Right here.
We'll figure this out with Ryan.
Try now.
Can you try it now or should I hang up?
Hang up and try it now and if it doesn't work,
call me back.
Alright,
he's trying.
Um,
yeah,
the,
uh,
the aquatic worm,
it's the weirdest one.
Grows inside of a grasshopper,
his body,
and then when it's ready to be hatched,
it tricks the grasshopper into committing suicide.
Yeah.
Is it coming in?
All right,
here we go.
Hello?
Hello.
Mr McAfee.
Yup.
It's Joe Rogan.
How are you sir?
Okay,
I'm doing good,
sir.
How are you doing?
I'm doing great,
man.
We're a,
we're online now.
So,
uh,
I want to thank you first of all,
for,
uh,
taking,
this,
uh,
conversation with us cause you don't know anything about this podcast and you
took a real chance and,
uh,
and doing this and I,
and I really appreciate that,
uh,
cause your story,
I'm saying your story is absolutely fascinating and it's a,
it really is a,
a privilege to be able to communicate with you while all this is going on
because it's,
you know,
as you know,
your story has become a bit of a pop culture legend right now.
Um,
and for folks who don't know what the story is,
you,
you founded a McAfee antivirus software,
a tremendously successful company,
but for the last five years you've been living in Belize.
So they live in like a character in a hunter s Thompson movie.
And,
uh,
now you're,
you're in a bit of a hot water and your,
uh,
you're,
you're on the lamb stating your case on your blog,
which is a official,
what is the,
the blogs name?
The blog,
the uh,
the URL for the blog.
Yeah,
I'm sorry,
who is mcafee.com or Twitter is a facial McAfee
and who is mcafee.com.
You're updating like on almost a daily basis.
This is all a,
you're writing all this stuff man.
Okay.
So,
um,
that is a very rare situation where a guy's on the lamb and while he's doing it
and he's making a blog,
are you doing this because you don't,
you fear that your story's not going to get out there clearly incorrectly.
Okay.
Wow.
So for people like Jeff Wise and,
and uh,
Joshua Davis of wired magazine,
and so the story was radically incorrect as they portrayed it
sort of off the rails.
Nutter who's living in this beautiful country and uh,
having a big party for your life.
It seemed like you were,
that's what that,
that's how they portrayed it.
Yeah.
To
quote specific drugs.
I say I was using like a MDPV,
which is methylenedioxy pyro.
Velaro uh,
now anybody,
anybody who knows it's about that drug knows it is the most addictive drug on
the planet.
People who started cannot start,
which means that as we're speaking,
I must be taking it.
So,
oh my God,
I'm sorry.
Rats or jumping out of my phone.
So the question is,
um,
do I sound like a demented,
paranoid schizophrenic or not?
Wow.
Well,
I would have to be like right next to you and looking in the eyes to answer that
honestly,
because some people,
some people are really good at being smooth and keeping it together while
they're all fucked up.
But this,
these patients about this,
let's just say what you're wanting for.
First of all,
your,
your next door neighbor turned up dead and,
uh,
you had to flee for your safety because you don't,
you,
you are,
you're sure rather that there's some sort of a conspiracy and that they're going
to try to not only blame you for that,
but you believe even possibly harm you or kill you.
Okay.
I barely knew the gentleman.
Oh,
okay.
And there was no dispute between you and this gentleman?
There was no dispute between you and this gentleman.
Okay.
Oh absolutely
not like my dogs.
He drank more than than,
than the average person.
Then I just,
I didn't get along and he did not like the dogs barking at night.
Like frankly I didn't like them parking night either.
They ignored me so I,
I understood his complaints but as,
as to being hostile or,
absolutely not.
But someone poisoned your dogs.
Okay.
They did.
And it was the night before.
It could not have been him.
He owned stocks himself or owned dogs.
Any dog love.
Right.
I don't know if whether you have talked to not joke with no dog lover.
No one who has dogs would ever,
ever arm another dog.
Certainly not that way.
And the poison us was the most horrible they were.
They were vomiting blood.
They were shitting blood.
I had to put them out of their misery.
No one would do that through a dog that they love dogs.
So you feel like someone else was involved and they did it.
And this man is being connected to that because he died.
Now why are they blaming it on you?
Yeah.
Okay.
I'll give you the history then.
The last day of April of this year,
uh,
I woke up at six in the morning,
two 42 armed soldiers in full riot gear,
trying automatic weapons,
storming my property in orange walk on the river.
Um,
though I was held in handcuffs behind my back from the song for 14 hours
without,
without food or water.
I,
at one point,
by the way,
I asked you a guard for food and water,
not just for me,
but for everyone else.
The guards response was,
do I look like a chef to you?
Now,
indeed,
he did not look like a chef.
So it was my mistake,
but it was not a pleasant day.
From that moment on,
I've had nothing but problems with the police and government.
The day afterwards,
I demanded an apology from the prime minister.
Um,
and I've been vocal and outspoken opponent ever since.
Now they thought that you were running a meth lab.
That was the accusation.
Correct?
Because you actually were doing some legitimate scientific work according to
what I've read was that you were trying to work on some new antibiotic that
comes from plants found in the rain forest.
Was that the idea?
Okay.
Well,
is this a new science called quorum sensing,
which involves communication between bacteria and there's not really an
antibiotic.
It was a topical anti septic,
but the fairly magical one,
by the way,
a week after the raid,
the government tried to charge me with Ronnie and antibiotics laboratory without
a license.
Um,
that's sales because it's first of all,
no such logs.
This,
uh,
after that they tried to charge me for hiring security cards without a license.
It's been going on nonstop for seven months
and the there now,
the other reason why they would suspect that there was some crazy drugs involved
was because of forum posts that have been attributed to you,
um,
that we're all about purifying w the,
the chemicals known as bath salts and turning them into some crazy,
new,
more concentrated form of something that makes you hypersexual.
And all these blog posts online were attributed to you.
Are these something,
these things you actually wrote?
Oh,
absolutely.
I worked you.
This side is blue.
What?
Blue Light.
This is the largest drug form in the world.
Um,
and basically 10 years ago,
a drug called m d t v Tan,
a mythical drug,
people claim to have found a with magical properties.
Um,
and the,
the myth continues on my post was claiming to have rediscovered the formula for
it.
Now the chemists online of go about 200 chemists on blue light all said this is
a hoax.
This is total nonsense.
And they wandered off the rank and file follow through with it.
I am a practical jokester.
I have a lot of free time.
And then I just like to have fun.
Some however rediscovered that formula.
I would go to bear bear laboratories in Germany with a formula and a sample and
demand a check for $1 billion.
I mean,
what,
what would I be doing here?
Um,
so you,
you think you would get $1 billion for some drug that,
uh,
makes you're hypersexual oh yeah.
Hot Rod.
6,000.
Okay.
Well,
let's,
let's say,
what do you think by Agra?
What's he saying that she,
Alice,
what do you think all these sucks drugs are?
They are marital age.
So a marital aid Ariful AIDS that enhance sex?
Yes,
I think so.
I think the president would be doubt about is the president of the company would
be down on his niece handed me the check going,
we now own the world.
Oh yeah,
of course.
So I mean what once you think trucks are all about sir?
Well I,
well yeah I think,
I think people draw the line with bath salts when you know,
I don't know the actual effects of it physically because I haven't experienced
them.
But when you know,
you see them attributed to people biting people's faces off and shit like that,
which is what we see in the news and the,
the crazy stories on the air with.com if you go or a.org if you go and read the
error,
would a trip reports of people who have taken that stuff.
It doesn't seem like a good experience at all.
So I don't know how that would be like
quality profitable posts or when it has nothing to do with bath salts.
It has to do with a drug called MTP v Chan right here.
We'd all of the methodology,
they had nothing to do with that.
It was a purely sexual enhancement.
Okay,
so the bath salts,
my mind,
it has nothing to you guys.
They just attributed that to quote bath salts.
This is again the mainline press doing what it does best,
less sensationalized as best speech can.
So,
but you know all about these chemicals in pretty intimate a order.
You mean you,
you know all the,
the various different chemical names and you know enough to troll these people
effectively.
Like so,
but you,
you,
you don't experience these drugs yourself.
Of course.
I know a lot of things.
I know a lot about Ip address of rectification.
I know not,
not know how to do it.
You know a lot of things that you do or not do.
I read,
I read sir,
I have plenty of time.
Oh,
I believe,
you know,
I'm listening.
First thing.
I won't,
I won't have our,
I believe you,
you,
I mean,
I'm not,
uh,
saying that I don't believe you.
I have no reason to question you.
I'm just thought it was a very strange thing to do to write this really
elaborate troll about sex.
You know,
about making,
you know,
you wanna jerk off to your Dick Bleeds.
I thought it was hilarious.
Okay.
Well I thought it was hilarious too,
but some people did not.
Listen,
this is how your neck for me,
if you,
if you search online for a thing called observational Yoga,
let me tell you this story.
A woman from the village voice running for the woman or the village.
Why?
She called me to make a comment on the potty publicize lawsuit between the
crunchy I'll was ready and a guy named Gregory Muccio and Greg were used to be
one of my yoga is yoga students.
Uh,
she had no sense of humor.
So she finally said,
what are you doing?
I said,
oh,
I'm running a punch of observational from yoga studios and beliefs.
She goes,
what's that?
I said,
well,
we've discovered that if you sit in an easy chair,
drink wine,
and eat or jurors and watch people do yoga,
you get exactly the same benefit.
And she said,
really?
So I stretched it on?
I said yes,
and we're still going to start opening up observational weight studios.
And I went on to say that it works for everything except we've had no sex with
observations.
We'll pay the concert pianist.
We had people watch people play piano all day long and they still can't play the
piano.
We don't know why.
Now obviously it's a fucking joke.
And what happens?
She published a story,
check it out on the web.
A long story about observational yoga.
I had friends,
fries,
requests from all over the world.
That's hilarious.
You did have this chemical lab on your lot is developing this antiseptic.
So that's where the confusion came in where people are like,
oh,
so this guy actually has all this equipment but he's not,
you know,
so you weren't,
you weren't doing any of that stuff that was said in that blog that was all in
humor,
but did they find any of those chemicals and substances when they raided your
place but they found them then they weren't illegal because those,
those substances aren't illegal.
Technically.
There was nothing in there,
but herbs that we had picked along the river,
a lot of alcohol because alcohol ethanol in order to extract what we were
looking for microscopes and a bunch of other stuff.
It was me running a mess up.
What on earth?
How would I sell it?
I would have to be competing with,
this is up in Mexico,
the gang to cut people's heads off just for looking at the,
well that's stupid.
Just to play devil's advocate,
if I,
if you were going to be this incredibly rich guy,
which by all reports you are living in this country,
having a 17 year old girlfriend,
which by all reports you do and you were my friend applauds you.
Congratulations.
Sorry.
I applaud you as well.
Um,
and you were trying to have a good time and you were cooking up some stuff and,
and I wouldn't,
I wouldn't necessarily think you would want to take it public.
I would think that that in and of itself,
you know,
cooking that stuff up and reporting about it online would,
would be enough.
I mean if you were a poor person and it was a,
an amazing business opportunity,
but I feel like a guy like you who moves down to believes with a shitload of
money,
you're already in it for the vacation anyway.
Why would you go back to work?
Why would you really try to pitch some hypersexual meth?
You know,
I,
I could see playing devil's advocate why people would think that that is the
story.
Could you,
could you see white people?
We can tell us the story
and
I hate to be cynical
of lots of cash that turn some women on.
I'm sorry to say that.
Then I will get trashed.
You're not going to get trashed.
That's honesty.
That's honesty,
man.
From your experience especially,
it's proven to be absolutely factual.
So you are in a sense you're saying,
I'm sitting here with some
been following the log and Samantha is probably,
she has,
she has more balls than any woman I have ever met and she is a fierce tiger,
like ball of fire and she is looking at me now like she's going to rip one of my
legs off or maybe both of my nuts.
I don't know
how hot is it
actually I'm talking about just as a,
as a,
as a tiger or someone that you would never ever want to fuck with,
so
she got more balls than me.
I see what you're saying.
Well you're trying to say is that even though money's an aphrodisiac,
it's not like you don't have respect for women and you respect women very much.
I know what motivates people.
I'd be stupid if I didn't.
Young girls.
Let's face it.
This is grass I'm in.
Dave says he wrote to keep me on the phone a long time.
Sure.
I will keep it on the phone as long as you need,
sir.
We'll,
we'll cool it down or down.
Take a deep breath
for a moment.
Hi Samantha.
How you doing?
What's going on?
Are you ticklish right?
Settle down.
Sorry.
My friend's retarded.
Are you having a,
you're a little bit angry.
Why are you angry?
Because of what John just said.
I think what you said was fairly mild.
He was just saying that you a,
you're a very powerful person.
You've got a strong presence.
You're feisty.
Feisty.
Yeah.
I don't think there's anything wrong with that.
You got to give him some slack.
So how long have you known John?
A year over year and a half.
Do you enjoy his company?
Would you,
uh,
would you be willing to,
to endorse his character?
Does he use Norton and buyers?
That's good.
So you guys have a good relationship.
Excellent.
All right.
You're a fascinating person.
Can I talk to John Again?
Thank you Samantha.
Thank you for that.
Seems
do cheese and natural and radio.
She said she should have her own show.
I want to get her on Howard Stern.
Howard Stern.
We'd find out what Sam was like in bed and I responded.
Yeah,
we get Sam on.
Howard stern returned to what Howard was like in bed.
Whoa.
Jesus.
How dare you sir.
You are living that life that everybody would say like one day man.
Fuck it.
I just want to retired some awesome country,
live on the beach and have lots of beautiful women around me.
That's you,
man.
You're really doing that.
Okay.
Exactly.
Living the life.
Well,
you weren't here no matter where you're living.
I swear it has been an improvement.
Well,
I,
I believe your situation right now is dire.
Um,
before this though,
you were living this magical life of retirement,
uh,
fantasies.
What would Ben think of is like the perfect sort of a,
a place to live as an ex.
Pat,
why did you decide to move to Belize?
It's the most beautiful country in the world.
Traveled.
I think there are a few countries I have not visited and beliefs is the most
beautiful.
Allows me to have a talk right in front of my house for the boat.
You can't do that in Florida and New York.
Anywhere on the Pacific.
The water is aquamarine blue.
The weather is spectacular.
You are around.
The fishing is great.
The diving is great.
It's a beautiful country.
Did you have a bunch of friends that live down there before you moved?
No,
I also would not as those here.
Really?
Why is that?
Oh,
you wanted to get away?
Yeah,
get away.
That's the whole key.
Um,
now w w what if anything,
does this have to do with you?
You had a business in America for awhile where you were doing some,
explain what you were doing with airplanes.
It was like some acrobatic sort of a contest you guys were doing with planes.
Like what were you doing?
Okay.
It was out of business at all.
I never took the time.
I never made it.
I lost $10 million on that whole affair.
It was just for fun.
It was for myself and my friends.
We flew these things called wing airplanes,
airplanes,
airplane engines,
but they look like motorcycles with wings.
It is a kick in the ass.
My policy,
if you've ever done it,
you will get addicted.
So for a few years,
that's what I was doing.
And then what happened that led you to quit doing it?
Didn't someone die?
Okay.
My nephew died and one of his passengers,
or there's a lawsuit from NASA.
The fact that I have,
I have,
I've had more lawsuits than God.
The um,
uh,
everything from someone tripping over a log on my property and suing me for $10
million to a wrongful death from the passenger in my,
in my nephew's airplanes.
Yeah.
That is an unfortunate aspect of our society that people look at any sort of a
situation where it involves dealing with a rich person as possibly a,
an opportunity to hit the lottery.
You know,
whether it's a altercations,
physical altercations,
or,
you know,
when a guy like you,
you're,
you're obviously a very successful man and you become a target for shysters.
Right.
Basically,
let me try,
this is strange.
I bought the house in Florida,
put a down payment down,
changed my mind a few days later and said,
you know,
I'm declining to contract,
keep the down payment.
I was sued for half a million dollars.
Even though two weeks later they resold the house for hundreds of thousands more
than my contract.
And they sued me.
Uh,
it's like,
yeah,
unbelievable.
They had,
they suffered no loss.
In fact,
they suffered a tremendous game by me,
Carrie canceling that contract.
It's a crazy world,
my friends.
Yeah,
it is a crazy world.
It's a crazy world.
And the legal system is most certainly not the most perfect setup.
But um,
when,
when you moved to Belize,
um,
did you,
were you aware of what their legal system was like?
Cause he,
you seem to be having a real hard time with like the powers that be there.
Did you know that it was like kind of fucking sketchy down there.
Okay.
Oh,
of course.
I knew it was sketchy.
I didn't realize it was this sketchy.
I didn't realize it.
As a rich foreigner,
you are,
are,
you are obligated to pay your dues.
That is,
you know,
if you're going to donate money,
I'm told I did more than $7 million worth of stuff in this country.
Uh,
but I did it in a way that the powers that be could not skim anything.
You know,
I bought boots for example,
for every police officer in orange walked history.
Um,
and I put,
I demanded an accounting who can switch boots.
Now what?
I'm going to be able to skim money off of that.
They say,
well,
came up some money and let us fight the foods while they would keep 99% and buy
two pairs of boots.
This is how it works.
The rest would go to their families and in their own pockets.
Well,
I don't play by those rules that it just is everybody off.
So the government says someone in for a donation.
This is prior to the last election.
When I heard what I heard the amount,
I said,
get the fuck off my property.
Well,
they are not used to people saying that.
How much are they asking for?
Okay,
2 million,
$2 million.
Jesus fucking Christ.
Well this is for one.
For one.
We're going to make one day we're going to make my life better.
They were going to give me all sorts of preferences.
I didn't want to hear the fucking preferences.
Get the fuck off my property.
There is no argument.
There's no question.
There is no communication here.
Just get the fuck off.
Yeah,
it seems to like that.
Just them off.
It seems like it would be nice to give them a little bit of money,
you know,
a nice to if they're really have the altruistic notions in mind of you know,
keeping the community and in good order and,
and governing things.
Well,
but it seems like you're dealing with a and an ancient system of corruption
that's almost unsurmountable when you deal with like,
is that what they call a banana republic?
Uh,
if this is way below over that or call the police was founded by talented,
my pirate Sanders still controlled by pirates
Saturday by pirates.
You will,
you rule through fear and you collect debts through extortion.
This is the way life is,
but they can't extradite you to America.
Is that,
is that the case?
Like if you're,
uh,
your lawsuits,
like do you have to go to America to deal with the lawsuits involving the plane
crash?
Well,
of course,
you know,
you're not,
the legal system works.
If,
if anyone ever did get a judgment,
which no one has at all these lawsuits,
all of them have failed.
I will settle nothing for a dime.
I don't care if it costs me $10 million,
I'll pay it.
I will.
I will find it rather than just someone a single time from suing me.
So,
but what if you ever do get a judgment taking collected anywhere?
This is the way the world works.
So if they did find you responsible,
it wouldn't matter.
They would be able to get to.
So it's not that you're in Belize for that reason,
of course,
but
oh,
those can anybody I liked to,
they're lawsuit.
The airplane didn't blog to me.
I was not even there at the time.
Right.
Everything was kosher.
Accidents happen.
I am sorry I lost a nephew in the,
in that crash.
So I,
I'm sorry that that someone lost a father and a husband,
but it was an accident for Christ sakes.
No one is going to find me guilty.
It's ridiculous.
They say,
and this has been going on for seven years and it's just very down until you pay
me,
but I will never pay.
I will never settle.
I will fight this if it takes 50 years and constantly my last penny because I
will not,
I will not submit to extortion.
Well it's,
it's kind of interesting that you would be held responsible for it.
When you think about the fact that who knows how many people die in motorcycle
accidents every year and that's thought to be a respectable normal activity that
although very dangerous when people die in it,
you don't go immediately looking for someone to sue because they were involved
in dangerous activity.
It's a,
I guarantee you you would if it was owned by Bill Gates or Steve Jobs or Wazniak
wore me.
Absolutely.
You would go after the person because that's what they do.
Exactly.
So now your situation is you,
you're on the run essentially.
Do you have official charges against you?
Okay.
I have no charges whatsoever.
So you just like,
you know what they want for questioning.
However,
I know how this system works.
After the,
after the questioning I empty tanks,
they can legally detain you for ever in this country with no charges.
And it's easy to mason jars because there's no law here.
Um,
even though even though it's on the books,
there no real law,
the law is ruled by the powers in the party.
And so,
you know,
I'm not turning myself in for questioning.
If you're going to crush him,
he call me on the phone.
I'll be happy to talk to you.
I'll answer anything you want to know.
But yet you still plan on staying in beliefs.
Okay.
It's my homes or I mean,
maybe you don't understand that,
that when you,
when you love the country and you love the people,
um,
and you love where you are,
it becomes your home.
Um,
so I don't care how bad it gets political Alec or how many nasty people show up
at the top of the government.
I will find it.
I will not leave.
Oh,
I understand that.
That's your position.
Um,
and I,
I understand your passion.
It's just very unusual that someone would be willing to deal with such dangerous
situations.
Um,
a lot of people,
uh,
would not have that sort of resolve in committing to a place to live.
Okay.
Oh,
when you're 67,
you're is very sense or you don't have a lot to risk.
You say that,
man,
but you're going way out of your way to speak to people like myself to speak to
Alex Jones today,
which I know you had a conversation with earlier,
but talking to people at wired,
telling your case,
you,
you obviously have a vested interest in staying alive and invested interest in
and telling the truth about your situation.
You're not a guy that's like looking for at the end,
even if they do get their hands on me,
this is the way the system works.
This is unjust.
They have been charged with bogus charges.
My website,
which is who is mcafee.com,
who is mcafee.com.
You will find email,
email.
The prime minister is listed there.
Demand that these people get released.
This is injustice at the highest order.
I may be an old man,
but they are all young men.
One of them is in his early twenties for the brand new baby.
His wife,
by the way,
was arrested and held for a week with a newborn baby before she was released.
Um,
you know,
anybody who aids in a,
he was arrested,
a cab driver who helped me.
He was arrested.
Um,
this is utterly,
utterly absurd because you are my friend.
You are therefore arrested and punished.
And by the way,
the prisons here are no joke.
There are no beds.
You have concrete floors,
there are other portlets.
There are no showers,
there is no fucking food.
So please everyone go to my side,
who is mcafee.com.
Look at the form mailed these idiots and asked for something,
released these people.
Is there a way to resolve the situation?
Is there a way in the corruption that you're talking about sounds so
overwhelming.
I mean,
it seems like if you go there and fight it,
it's almost like swimming into the ocean and hoping to hit land.
It's almost like an insurmountable task.
Okay.
It's 70% of this economy depends upon tourism.
If the outside world gets pissed off and off,
the government will listen.
If 70% of any economy disappears,
that country collapses.
At some point they will have to yield.
I will stay like this.
I will forever and I will continue to ride forever.
Those are the only two options.
Well,
I can certainly tell you this.
Listening to your story has made me not want to go on vacation there.
I would never go on vacation because if the shit hit the fan,
it sounds like the places controlled by fucking crazy people.
Okay,
well
harass you with law of swap music outside your house for hours.
If you,
I don't understand what you're saying.
If I did it,
you have to.
You have,
he wants you to eat
blog and then I'm going to come after you and play in front of your house was a
wonderful man and he played some beautiful music.
But I will,
I will.
Isn't that how they got Noriega out?
Didn't they play Metallica or something like that?
I think they played,
like I said,
isn't that how they got Noriega to come out of,
uh,
he was,
held up in the house when they finally arrested him
three years.
Right.
Um,
so you,
you're still,
you still believe that this can be resolved and you can go back to Belize and go
back to living your wonderful life in your home.
I really am crazy.
So you believe that by exposing all this corruption short as it's sort of
shedding a turning a lot of negative publicity on the way the government is
running,
believes this could hurt their economy and it can make them reconsider and
become nicer.
Like what's,
what's,
how's it going to get you back?
I believe,
you know,
I certainly believe you,
but you,
it just seems like you're in this situation where you're dealing with so many
dangerous folks.
I couldn't imagine you not wanting to just get the fuck out of there and maybe
come back to America or our system of laws a little bit more obvious.
Yeah.
Okay.
Well,
there are a couple of issues.
Number one,
I'm traveling with a young woman whose life
threatening,
threatened,
even suggested again.
So
yeah.
Um,
or,
or don't be around people that are thinking about cutting you.
That's another option.
Figure of speech.
Yes sir.
I did not in any way mean to imply that she would ask do it.
We know,
we know we were just joking around with you,
but let's listen man,
it's great that you have such a loyal companion.
Please forgive me.
It's great that you have such a loyal companion in this terrible time of crisis.
Now,
how are you,
uh,
I mean,
without giving away your location and you know,
giving away your methods of concealment,
can you tell us about how you're,
how you're living?
Well,
some warm showers
until you lose everything you have no what's truly valuable to me.
Number one,
other than food of course,
hot showers,
you have no fucking clue what life was like without it.
Um,
so we're living on hog today.
Now you may think we're living in a hovel of a fourth today.
I'm Irene,
I'm in hog heaven.
Uh,
my life has not been exactly pleasant.
if I've been moving frequently,
sometimes every four hours,
sometimes once a day.
Um,
again,
my biggest concern is making sure that Sam is safe.
Um,
moving with Sam is a lot more difficult of course,
because people are looking for a,
an elderly white man and a cute young girl.
Well,
Gee Whiz.
Um,
you know,
how hard is that the spot and yet we've managed for almost three weeks through
AGSM already.
So no,
I can,
I plan on continuing to do it until my dying day if necessary.
So the idea is not to hold up until you get this resolved.
The idea is to just hold up to the end.
Okay.
Well,
I guess this was all if I get this resolved.
So that is again,
to not go home with me and we go back to swimming and fishing and,
and,
and sitting in the song.
Okay.
Now you've used a bunch of different elaborate disguises too,
that you were pretty open with different things that you did to,
to hide your appearance.
Okay.
Yes.
What did you do?
I actually,
I actually at the Financial Times reporter Adam Thompson came,
he was actually going to come in and,
and,
and stay with us for a length of time and chronicle our fans.
But she kind of freaked out after he got here and,
and,
and it seriously freaked out the end and beg to leave after four hours.
He didn't get four hours of tapes interview on his,
his,
um,
his story will appear in the London Financial Times on the 7th of December.
It shouldn't be a fascinating story.
Wow.
Um,
I felt,
I felt so much from that and I chose him because he wasn't objective wider.
It did not occur to me.
And this is how stupid I am.
Just someone who was a fine answer reporter might not be suited for this life.
Wow.
So he at least he hung in there for four days,
so he'll get an accurate assessment.
No,
it's not a full decade.
Not even on it.
She hung in here for four
Oh,
for four hours.
Jesus Christ.
I wrote,
I wrote on the block.
At one point,
Sam said,
she really,
I mean,
he really railed on,
she says,
I'm a girl.
I'm small.
I'm 20 years old and I have more balls than you have
before.
Pastor was really taken back and I laughed and said,
don't worry about it.
She's got more balls than me to no,
take it personally.
There's a,
there's an ebook about you that's,
it started off as an article in wired,
but it became so interesting that this writer can construct it.
An ebook and a he,
there's,
they're selling it now,
I believe on Amazon,
right?
Oh yeah.
Josh Davis.
Yeah.
Josh is not one of my favorite people.
Yeah,
sure.
You host do a
story of the arrest and,
and the right.
I said,
okay,
I'm under this condition.
If it's drifted devolves into a personality piece,
I'm not going to cooperate because that's how people are wired.
Omics,
personality.
I do have an outside environment,
which is interesting,
but people prefer to write about whatever I am.
Well,
you're an awesome personality.
I believe that you're an awesome personality.
I believe,
first of all,
you're a very successful businessman.
You're obviously a very intelligent person,
but let's be honest,
you're an awesome personality.
You're 67 years old,
you're 67 years old.
You live in the beach and believes in this incredible compound with 11 dogs.
You have really hot girlfriends and the legend is you cook meth.
That's a fascinating story.
People would want to hear that.
Once they chip away at all that and get to who they really are.
This will not be a personality rise.
This will be a story about corruption and it ends up being an ebook with
my favorite person.
Halfway through it,
I figured out what was going on.
I understand.
I understand why
you can ask him,
listen,
I'm writing a story about you while you're writing a story about mine will come
out first.
Well,
I understand that what's really important to you is to get out the reality of
the corruption and believes and that's what was important about.
But do you understand that more people are going to read that piece because they
got a picture of you naked with a shotgun?
It's really hard to find pictures of me naked with a shotgun
corruption.
No,
but I disagree sir.
And this is why,
because I think it turns eyes on it.
And your amazing personality is making people aware of this corruption.
That's how I'm becoming aware of it.
I wouldn't become aware of it if it wasn't for the fact that it makes for this
sensational story,
whether or not most of the aspects of it are true or not.
You have to understand that that's why people are paying attention.
People love a crazy train wreck and a billionaire who's shirtless holding guns.
That's the kind of shit people want to see.
When a guy is 67 years old and he lives in a beautiful paradise with hot chicks
and he's got a fucking gun and he's not wearing a shirt.
That's the kind of shit people want to see through that you can get your story
and your information and what's really important for you to to reveal this
corruption,
but you have to understand that that makes it appealing.
That's,
that's what's exciting about it to people,
human
relationships.
So Josh violated your trust.
Very unjust fashion.
So Josh violated your trust by,
by making it a personality piece.
Yeah,
I understand.
So you're just not interested in revealing those aspects of your personal life
and you thought that by having him and having him over in confidence,
he would not make it about that.
I totally understand the agreement.
I totally understand that sir.
That was since it was,
I'm not a stupid person,
but still a little bit clever.
I go,
okay,
this is the way it is.
I'm going to just use you as a springboard,
which I did.
Well and I appreciate that you did do that.
So that's how I,
how I found out about your blog and I think that's one of the most beautiful
things about this day and age is that a guy like you really cannot be
misrepresented because you can represent yourself and you can put your own words
down in a blog and have an answer for every question instead of just leaving
things up to your accusers.
Especially in a situation like yours where you're on the run,
you still have the opportunity to put up your version of the things word for
word,
exactly how you want it distributed and uh,
that,
that's a rare thing about our time and this conversation that we're having right
now.
Same thing.
You,
you have a rare opportunity to state your case emphatically
telling him to fuck off.
I'm talking to real time
the resources
and you have the viewership listenership,
which is completely different.
I can talk to you and you can ask me anything,
my sexual preferences or stolen.
I will answer honestly because it comes from my lips.
If I talk to CNN,
they're going to edit it to the point that I still come off like a raving
lunatic and coming out of the telephone.
It's a dying method of getting information.
It just,
it doesn't make sense the way it's broken up in commercials and designed to
sandwich products in between that you don't want.
It's a dying way of distributing information.
It just doesn't,
it doesn't hold up in the,
in the the age of the Internet,
but I think this is one of the rare cases in as far as like a big news story
like yours where a guy gets to really tell his story to a bunch of different
venues,
whether it's Alex Jones or me or whether it's your blog or whether it's your
Twitter,
you,
you a official macafee Twitter,
you were able to tell your side of things in a way that we've never seen before.
Like could you imagine when Oj was on the run if Oj a video blog and he got to
tell his story?
Yes,
possibly.
Yeah.
I mean,
who knows.
Lee Harvey Oswald could have had a fucking blog.
That would have been a,
an interesting,
it was Michael Jackson.
Remember that far back?
Michael Jackson and the young boy were headlines and then suddenly everybody
forgot about him and,
and,
and started looking at Oj.
So if it had to be a Michael Jackson,
that's hilarious.
Um,
I don't think that's correct,
but,
uh,
but it was a joke.
I know it was a junk man.
I'm a,
I'm reacting to it as if I'm retarded.
Bobo killed it.
Where was the monkey mind?
No,
no worries man.
Um,
do,
do you,
are you comfortable with this position of being this guy who's on the run and,
uh,
you know,
being this guy who's accused of a horrible crime and having this really crazy,
wild lifestyle?
Is this,
uh,
are you enjoying this stage of your life other than the fact that you're on the
run?
Um,
I mean,
I would much rather have the freedom of movement.
I'd like to jump in my pool and sunlight and sit at the end of this talk and
throw a fishing line in the water.
Just getting the boat and Bob around for awhile.
But now this is,
this is not something I'm comfortable with.
It's something I'm coping with their,
there's a difference.
How many people have a negative reaction to your lifestyle,
to the lifestyle that you were leading before you got into trouble with the
Belize government?
The older guy with the young chicks partying all the time.
Yeah.
Well I would say 90%.
The partying all the time does not exist.
Not the way people think there was partying.
Okay,
okay.
So I mean even just hanging out with a 20 year old naked,
that shit's partying.
That's how I look at it.
I went to party with you.
I don't mean party and by like the,
the drugs that you were trolling people on taking,
um,
I don't mean to imply that,
but I mean to apply that you're living like a,
a pretty festive lifestyle down there.
I still enjoy that a little bit.
Here
was the,
the was there blow back from like the the locals at all?
Like,
how do they feel about this older rich guy moving in and,
and banging all these young hotties?
I hated it.
Okay.
He's,
then they would imagine their husbands in the same situation.
Then suddenly I was the devil incarnate.
Yeah.
Isn't that funny that people give a shit about what you can pull off,
you know,
and shouldn't you be happy when you see a guy who's in his sixties is managed to
pick up some 20 year old hot chicks?
It everybody be happy.
This is that.
That's possible.
Why does one man success?
I'm happy when I see anybody enjoying themselves and being happy because my God,
you know the,
the person next to you,
it's just like yourself.
You know,
we're,
we're not,
we're not as separate as you think.
We are all each other and so yeah,
the,
the rational and sane person with a heart,
it's always happy when I see another person happy.
That's why we smile when other people smile.
Yeah.
What is it about other people's success that for some reason with weak minded
people it is somehow or another they feel like it's taking away from them.
Like they want to attack you,
they won't attack you for your success.
A 67 year old guy that get bank,
20 year old girls wins everywhere in the world.
Is there any protection at the u s offers in a situation like this?
Like can you go to like the embassy or,
or,
or whatever the yeah,
that's a good question.
Yeah,
of course.
I can go to the embassy.
The problem is everybody has a false idea of how much power an embassy has.
It is a tiny little building in a foreign country.
Um,
uh,
I could go to the embassy,
there are two options afterwards.
I'd have to stay there forever.
Like Juliana Tsonga,
um,
or leave the embassy and face of media or the rest.
I mean,
I'm a see isn't going to go,
hey,
let this man out of prison.
They're going to say you do
well,
you're a man of considerable resources.
I mean,
I would think that a guy with a,
you're kind of wealth would be at least be able to arrange for some sort of,
uh,
illegal meeting with someone in the United States to help you get back.
Is,
has that been done at all?
Okay.
Hello?
Well,
you're assuming I want to get back,
but you know,
as I stated earlier,
I don't want to get back
even just to get one belief,
even just to get to safety mean while you're on the run.
I mean,
you,
you would rather stay on the run and believes then be like comfortable in
America and just sort things out.
I do not think I'm going to,
I don't think I'm going to be on the run forever.
In fact,
I seriously do not think I'm going to be on the one from last longer.
What's the plan?
The government,
the government is not stupid.
And I know for a fact that the tourism has to have been impacted by this affair
and not in a positive way,
sir.
Um,
and given the fact that tourism is 70% of the economy,
uh,
I believe that eventually common sense will prevail.
I really do.
And some accommodation will be reached.
Okay,
so that's they have other suspects or do you know what's going on with the case
of the guy who was murdered?
Well,
if they have other suspects,
I pumped into pursuing them.
Um,
you know,
they still have not named to me is the suspect.
They just named me as someone they want to talk to you.
But this is Felice.
The last person who gave him sit off in for,
for talking was a guy named Arthur Young.
They hand trust his hands behind his back and shot him 14 times in a police fan
because they claim with his hands handcuffed behind his back.
He attempted to wrestle a weapon away from one of the 10 officers in there with
him.
Oh,
please get a clue.
People.
Okay.
But yet you still want to there,
this is amazing that you,
you think that this can be worked out.
The average police policemen has,
it has a decent person dollar an hour for Christ's sakes.
So obviously they're going to be corrupt,
corrupt to the point that they have to,
they have to augment their income in some fashion.
It's not the police.
It's a very few,
highly,
very powerful.
How these place officials who are very powerful,
who have bled for this country dry.
This is the problem,
sir.
The people can,
people,
people can be removed from office.
That's what I was just gonna say.
You're such a bad mother fucker.
Why don't you just run beliefs?
You love it.
It's a great place.
I don't want to run the voice.
I don't want any power.
I want to fish and play
and enjoy my friendships
and do it as the king of beliefs.
You can run it.
You have
a
political person.
Good Lord.
I don't want that responsibility,
Mr. Magnesium.
I'm joking.
I don't really think that you could ever be the king of beliefs.
It's just joking,
sir.
No,
I understand that.
But keep in mind for my is nice humor.
Maybe stress a little 10 due to my circumstances and lack of sleep.
Oh,
absolutely.
Uh,
you,
you have been an amazing interview and,
uh,
your character holds strong and,
in this terrible situation that you find yourself in,
you,
uh,
you can keep it together.
Admirably is very good talking to you.
I really appreciate you taking the time and using your cell phone credits and
uh,
you know,
and
who is,
who is mcafee.com and our Twitter side official McAfee
and McAfee for folks who don't know is spelled m c a f e,
e m.
C,
a.
F.
I thought it was McAfee all this,
all these years.
I really,
I called it macafee over and over again.
It's McAfee.
Sorry about that.
That's what I believe.
Well listen,
it was a,
it's an honor to talk to you sir.
Uh,
I wish you all the best of luck down there and uh,
I hope you can find safety and security and everything works out.
Thank you very much.
Joe Official McAfee
on Twitter and who is mcafee.com.
Thank you sir.
Ride like the wind,
my friend and,
and keep living that dream life,
Paula.
Well,
that's,
what was that like Brian?
Um,
that was interesting.
Fascinating.
Right?
Yeah.
I think it's really silly that he wants to stay there though.
I,
if I was him,
I'd get the fuck out of there.
Deal with it from afar using lawyers or would like some other kind of way and
then return there when you can because it seems like it just doesn't seem smart
to what
was very,
it was like conflicted because he would tell you that it's so corrupt,
it's fucked up and the murder people and you turn yourself in,
they shoot you in the van.
Right.
And then he's like,
but it is my home and this,
those people,
I make a dollar an hour and it's like,
like,
I'm going to get dollar an hour so it's okay.
They shoot people in a fucking van,
like what's going on here?
Like he's all over the road.
And if that could really say,
he was just gonna slice her throat,
she probably murdered the guy,
you know?
She's like,
well,
this is money.
I'm not letting anyone get involved with this guy.
Yeah.
Right.
Like he poisoned his dogs.
All right bitch.
I'll go.
But shooting in the fucking head
and poison like I want to know the dog.
I don't believe that the girl did it though.
Yeah,
I don't eat it,
but I want to know like the dog being poisoned and like this guy that that has
been shot.
Is there any DNA going on?
Is there any,
well actually a good point.
Is there an answer that,
okay,
what?
What is one way to tell is they actually,
when the guy was shot,
they have a ballistics on the bullet and then when the dogs were poisoned,
McAfee had to put the dogs down.
So they actually dug up,
the dog's cut,
the dog's heads off,
and they took the dogs' heads to forensics labs.
So they were trying to prove that the bullets that killed the guy or the same,
the killed the dogs,
which would mean that McAfee,
but they haven't been able to do that.
And if they did that would be like big news.
You know,
they can't see,
they can't fake that kind of science.
If McAfee has the gun,
you can't,
that's ballistics.
You couldn't,
you couldn't rig ballistics.
People would say,
well,
can we see the bullet?
What did you do?
Like,
let's see the physical evidence.
Is there one hair of his at this guy's house while they,
well,
it
could be that he visited the guy.
That doesn't mean anything either.
They're their neighbors and they did have a dispute.
So they did communicate.
But you know,
the other thing that I didn't buy was,
so when he said that people who are dog lovers would never poisoned a dog.
There's some sociopathic assholes out there.
That's not true.
That's crazy.
There's people that want their sleep and they're like,
fuck it.
I'm going to poison his dogs.
There's definitely people who have dogs who will poison your dogs.
That I didn't,
that I didn't.
Uh,
but the other,
the other thing is like,
he knows way too much about drugs.
I've never done drugs.
Right.
That was nuts.
What he's telling us,
all the different compounds and the,
the,
the sexual hype stuff,
if you read the stuff online,
folks,
if I think he said,
it's blue light.com.
Let me,
let me Google it for you on blue light.
It's fun.
I don't know if it's true,
but it is fucking fascinating,
the story of this guy cooking this shit up.
I mean him,
he says it's just horse shit.
He says he was fucking around.
Um,
and trolling,
that dude could probably hack our computers if he McAfee.
And by the way,
he's,
you know,
he obviously has a troll a little bit like,
he does fuck around with people like the whole idea yoga thing.
No,
I don't think it is that they're really looking for him.
But the yoga thing,
you know,
like if it was a troll,
it's a brilliant way to,
uh,
to start up,
like maybe just a blog.
I'd like to get people to read,
listen to and read his blog up and millions
of people reading this fucking blog.
Yeah.
But voodoo chicken is the first guy who turned me onto it and he put it on the
Rogan board and I read his,
uh,
his take on it and I was like,
this is fucking bananas.
Like this,
this guy,
if he was really was doing that,
was hyper concentrating this drug,
whatever the fuck it is that makes you ridiculously hypersexual,
you know,
and then taking it and fucking this 17 year old girlfriend.
But the thing is,
he does have a 17 year old girlfriend.
He at least he did have a 17 year old girlfriend when he was doing this.
Now he's got a 20 year old,
you know,
she's tiny.
She's the one who was on wanting to cut them and asleep.
She's 20.
Wow.
Just joked about cutting them in his sleep rather.
Um,
so he,
he is obviously a little twisted just period,
sir.
Just yet sir.
Nothing wrong with it.
I mean,
but he's,
you know,
he's acting as if he's all respectable and everything,
but you still banging 17 year olds,
like he's not,
I'm not saying that he's doing those drugs,
but at least he knows a shitload about those drugs.
He knows enough to talk about it and he's banging a 17 year old
and if you're really rich and your neighbor's dogs,
right.
Barking a lot.
Yeah.
Well see that.
That's just speculation.
Who knows what the fuck,
you know,
who knows when it comes to that?
Who knows whether or not the guide poisoned his dog.
But I do know that,
you know,
McAfee's he's,
he's out in,
they're having a great fucking time.
I don't think he's being completely honest.
Brought that whole drug thing.
He knows too much about that shit.
I don't know.
Maybe he is just trying to make boner
pills.
Um,
I don't think that's what he's saying.
No,
it doesn't give you a bonus.
It just makes you a really horny and likes you rub yourself and know,
like people were rubbing themselves raw.
He was saying that was his description of it,
which again,
could be fucking trolling.
It could be trolling.
I wish it wasn't though.
It's much more fun to think that it's just some nutty,
true story.
No,
I don't know,
man.
The guy is a,
he's quite a character.
But it's funny because he's not willing to,
you know,
like he was upset that this guy had written this piece about him that made him
out to be this wild fucking maniac.
But yet he's walking around shirtless with a fucking shotgun while they're
taking pictures.
Like it's really hard to find pictures of you shirtless with a shotgun
shirtless just per period.
Yeah.
But shirtless with his shotgun I take,
I keep my shirt on in the shower.
It's impossible
to find a photo of you shirtless with a shotgun and less you're shirtless with a
shotgun.
Yeah.
And you own a shotgun.
Well he does live in living in Belize,
man.
And I thank you.
Would
silly if you're living anywhere where you need a shotgun,
you're probably
not.
It's probably not the most amazing place.
Like what?
I,
I have a doc in front of my house.
Well you can have a dock in front of your house in Ohio,
you know,
in front of a lake,
whatever.
So my Internet problem over at my office sucks of Fatty Dsl.
This is all I can get there privately.
No,
you can definitely get some kind of cable.
I don't know.
Solutions team like they have,
it might have to get something else like a t three or some shit.
I didn't even know how those work.
I have to get those installed.
I don't know what it is or expensive.
Uh,
stupid.
Stupid.
I've been,
I'm in a bad spot.
No,
you can get,
you can get cable.
I'm sure there's a time Warner or charter with four g internet you can't do like
from cell phones and shit.
It's too,
that's silly.
Not Strong enough.
No.
And you'll run out of bandwidth immediately,
right?
They would.
They would fuck you with that too.
Isn't it funny how like you can use all the bandwidth you want if you have an
internet connection,
but if you have a cellular Internet connection,
that Shit's cap motherfucker.
Yeah,
it's not ready yet.
It's,
well,
you're just sharing it with too many.
If you,
if everyone was doing that,
no one would have so many people.
If they don't have access for that many people,
uh,
they don't have access for people streaming Netflix.
Like if everyone was streaming Netflix and doing video conferencing and that'd
be just reading.
I don't think they should give you an open ended device,
like a phone that has internet access on it and say you could only use it a
certain amount other than that's stupid.
I think that's that,
that,
that to me and if everybody uses it at the same time,
it doesn't work,
then you're selling too many phones because you don't have the backbone to deal
with it.
Well,
most of the time,
most people aren't using it,
so they'll tell we have it set up.
No,
no.
That's like saying that you're going to put all your money in the bank and then
the bank only has like half your money there.
And then when people want it all at once,
so while we don't have it,
well that's stupid.
What'd you do with my fucking money?
You can't,
they don't.
That's a bad analogy.
But point stands,
you shouldn't be selling a fucking cell phone with Internet on it until you have
the backbone to give everybody Internet.
If they use it all at once.
That's how it should be.
It should be that everyone with a fucking cell phone can use it and in time,
all day long,
every fucking cell phone could be downloading something big at the same time.
That's when you're ready.
That's when you're ready to sell it.
You fuck heads there.
They're selling it when it's not ready.
They're selling you some shit that's not quite there.
It's like,
well,
we kind of experimental.
It's almost there.
Well,
we call it four G,
but everybody can't use it at the same time.
Give it to us at all.
I'd rather them get their shit together.
Motherfuckers.
This guy's a McAfee's down there.
I guess he's using,
I don't know.
What kind of phone is your bank?
Robber phones.
Yeah,
those,
those portable ones.
That dude's get when they,
well wait.
He probably has satellite.
He's probably got the deed from virgin.
Probably dropped him on creative satellite phones.
Well,
I wonder if he has any friends down there.
That's what's really interesting and powerful.
He's doing it.
It's a,
it seems,
I mean I did want to ask him how he's hiding,
but he was pretty open about certain aspects of it and other interviews.
Color in his face like with shoe Polish and shit and,
and you know,
putting stuff in his mouth to make it look he's fat.
Well,
I'm thinking that he was just straight up dressed up as a girl,
you know,
I was doing that too.
That's a good mood.
But that will be obvious.
Not really.
I mean his girlfriend has balls,
she just has balls in her personality.
Brian,
he fucking 12 year old.
How dare you.
That would be funny if she had real ball.
That's got to suck though to be like almost 70 years old and fucking hiding.
Yeah,
but it's also,
come on man,
just get out of there.
Are you being silly?
If you're living in a country that has those kinds of laws,
like the laws where they can arrest you for life.
You don't want to live in that country because he's like,
if you do one thing wrong,
what you're going to go to prison.
You have that.
It might be pretty outside,
but you have to live in some kind of sick,
safe,
like no bullshit kind of government thing that there has to be laws.
Yeah,
I couldn't rock that.
I couldn't,
I couldn't live down there where you got to worry about being when you get up,
it's almost ego for him staying there.
Well,
he's obviously got a big ego.
He's super successful guy.
All of those,
all super successful billionaire characters,
they all have strong egos.
They all think they're bad motherfuckers.
That's they are.
That's how they got to be where they are and then they see all these monkeys
that are asking them for millions of dollars and I'm like,
bitch,
you ain't running me out of town.
It's where I live.
He's got his house there.
That's where he lives.
When you live somewhere for five fucking years,
that is where you live.
Um,
but 2 million bucks,
man,
they're asking for 2 million bucks.
That's gotta suck some knocks on your door and ask you for $2 million.
Like what?
$2 million?
A lot of fucking money.
Even for a billionaire to give to some political douche rag in a crazy little
island that was founded by pirates or wonder what's going to happen here when
you know,
you do that ice house game where you,
uh,
you watch the video,
pause it,
you pause it and say what happens next?
And then you do a bunch of really fucked up endings to videos.
What if you had to do that with this?
If you had a pause this right now and say what happens next?
What would be your guests?
Uh,
he gets arrested.
You think so?
Yeah.
Why do you think so?
Well,
I mean it's just getting sloppy for him.
I think I like,
I mean like if you,
and unless beliefs has like,
you know,
a,
a donkey in their,
in their government office,
you know,
just sitting there with a bucket and like,
a donkey and they're like,
all right,
let's find this guy.
You know,
like,
I don't know how,
like is this place high tech at all?
Do they have a real government?
Do they have a real,
you know,
like FBI type thing going on there?
That's a good question.
I don't even know how big believes is.
Yeah.
Like it could be like the whole,
the whole,
you know,
people looking for them.
It could be like two guys in a jeep,
you know?
Yeah,
that's true.
Right.
It could be like the Iraqi army before we invaded.
Yeah,
because I mean like it,
just listening to this whole interview,
you know,
I heard sounds in the background,
the sound,
at one point it sounded like somebody was tapping at bowl out.
Uh,
I heard what sounded like a dog at one point.
And so like if there was a guy really looking for this person,
I'm sure they could probably,
you know,
the decipher background noises and interviews and,
and Ip addresses.
And like,
they're really that phone number that he called from has to have a IP address or
some kind of like,
you know,
it's using a cell phone tower.
They've,
and this place isn't,
he's a clever guy though.
I'm sure he's masking it somehow.
It must be satellite.
Well,
he's on the ball as far as like technology's concerned.
I bet he being a virus,
uh,
the manufacturer of virus software,
the biggest one of the biggest virus software companies on the planet,
that guy must be so technologically literate.
He must know how to,
how to mask things and hide things.
And,
well,
what,
I wonder how much McAfee and Norton created virus in the 90s and 2009 they
created,
they created a company.
I mean,
if you think about it,
it's like,
hey,
there's these things called viruses c and then we have the way to stop them.
You know,
I actually never considered that,
but would be good business.
Fuck yeah.
There'll be smart business.
If you could do that.
He probably is trolling all of us with this virus.
Shit.
He invented viruses.
Yeah.
Came up with virus protection software.
He's a bad ass mother fucker salts and 17 year olds.
This,
um,
this truck,
I want to know more about this fucking drug cause,
uh,
I,
I've never heard of it before this
mmm.
This situation because I had never known that there was anything that that makes
you like hypersexual
mmm.
Does Dick Pills I,
you know,
I take,
but those,
they'll just make your dick hard.
Right.
They make it not go away though.
Like I,
they,
they make you not be able to come.
Oh really?
Yeah.
And it's just like,
all right,
I have a quiet,
well,
I found it.
I've been doing a lot of research on him lately.
And what happens is the first couple of hours you take them,
you can get hard quick and,
and uh,
it's like,
it lasts a little long,
but you,
you can come on it.
But if you've tried to fuck like six hours later,
it's like you have a morning Boehner that won't go away and you can't come at
all.
What is in it?
It makes your decor.
I don't know.
I think it's aunts,
it's something extracted from aunts and it's called hot hot rod.
A 5,000 or I don't recommend leave work,
but it really works.
I recommend it for special occasions,
but that Shit's rough when you have a hard on that they won't stop.
You can't come.
It's great if you have a 17 year old girl and you're running away doing yoga,
you're fucking her in a gutter.
Yeah.
I don't know.
See this,
this thing about McAfee,
I don't know if he,
uh,
I don't know how much of it is really trolling or if he ever did do this stuff.
Yeah.
I mean,
it's pretty funny that it's McAfee.
the whole thing sounds like a humongous troll.
I mean,
I haven't done any research,
so I have no idea of any of this is true.
I,
you know,
uh,
but what if it was,
you know,
just dude,
that's a great troll.
Especially.
It's amazing.
What if it's Norton?
Wow.
Yeah.
I don't know,
man.
The whole thing.
This and MDPV,
have you ever heard of this before?
Now it's recently banned in the US,
but it's legal and beliefs.
It belongs to a class of drugs called Catherine owns a natural source of which
is the east African plant cat.
You know,
a k h a t is,
that's that shit that,
um,
those guys take the Somali pirates,
they chew this stuff called cat and it's a,
it's like an amphetamine.
They chew it and they fucking go berserker if the fact that it's called cat just
makes me think this is more of a troll.
No,
no,
no.
The actual drug is a long,
it's not,
it's more of a joke,
right.
More of more evidence of simulation theory.
MDPV is serious shit who explain his paranoia.
And so one of them on the website wrote his paranoid erraticness.
I've been through that.
I played with MDP be for about two weeks.
Then I started seeing shadow people in the corner of my eye and what amphetamine
heads called tree cops.
It's essentially really fucked up math.
Um,
I forgot to ask him about this.
He had some thing where he called into a guy from,
I think it was a guy from wire that he was talking to.
It might've been this Josh guy that he hates now and told him that the cops were
outside and that there was like 30 of them standing on the beach outside of his
condo and he couldn't move cause they would shoot him.
So he just stood there and they stood there and no one said anything for hours.
And they went away at like four o'clock in the morning and he's like,
it was fucking really weird,
really weird.
And so to escape,
he climbed into his neighbor's balcony and his neighbor found him covered in his
own urine.
Why?
That's the official story asleep and it pissed all over himself.
That's the,
that's the story.
Now whether or not I wanted to ask him whether or not that was true because if
he was suffering from extreme paranoia and this,
this statement that he gave explaining that these cops were out there and they
were just standing there staring at him and no one said anything and he couldn't
move.
Cause if he moved they were going to shoot him and he's talking about a
shoulder's killing him because he was leaning up against it and he dared not
move.
And then finally at like four 30 in the morning,
they just like went away.
It was like,
what kind of a Co Raisie story is that?
I forgot to ask him about that one.
Caught.
Dammit.
I think the dude's might be on the MDPV.
Oh,
I don't want to be arrested.
He's got some bitch and tattoos.
I look at that as tribes sexy as fuck.
I don't want to be sued.
Now.
Would that be ironic if he sued us because we said he's coming.
It might be on it.
Yeah,
he did.
Did warn me.
I don't really believe he's on that shit.
I don't know.
I don't know what MDPV actually does,
but he was saying that you can't do it and not get addicted to it,
but apparently that's not necessarily true.
Like this guy was that he did it for two weeks
and he stopped doing it and he was writing a report on it.
There's a lot of reports in this shit.
Um,
he,
a Guy Paul early,
his a a addiction specialist and he warns about the dangers of NPV MDPV.
He says a hour experience,
clearly warrants of the psychiatric and medical dangers of this drug.
We have cared for multiple patients who have abused MDPV and they report intense
and unpleasant visual hallucinations after a short bench.
That drug feels nontoxic with its first use.
But following moderate binge users suffer from mild to moderate paranoia.
And about 10% of them,
end of individuals who have,
who use higher doses.
We have observed a sustained psychotic state with intense anxiety lasting three
to seven days.
Wow.
So this guy is just outright saying on Gizmodo that he used this stuff.
MMM.
Even though McAfee is saying that it's all a troll,
I think even if you don't know what to troll,
you have to say that McAfee says as a troll.
Right,
don't you?
Uh,
yeah.
I,
I'm more,
I don't know.
I have no idea.
I want to believe this guy,
but it's why it just makes no sense.
Like WWE,
like here's a lot of,
there's a lot of things in his story that just like a common sense person would
be like,
okay,
no,
I'm going to the u s embassy.
No,
I'm going to escape and figure this out.
You know,
I am not going to be living in wherever he's living in.
Yeah.
You would say,
I've got to get in the boat and I'm going to fucking go to Cuba.
Right.
Or whatever's close.
I mean,
if I believe where's bleach?
I don't know how far away that shit.
I don't know it just South America.
I have no idea.
Each son of a bitch.
I'll tell you what in the bellies picture,
if you go to [inaudible] dot com it's all just white people,
white people holding hands.
My other bull barefoot with their feet up.
Isn't it having a time of their life like people
both the least connected to United States in a way like,
isn't that like are they are buddies?
Yeah.
Like isn't it supposed to be like we were like a Puerto Rican kind of thing?
No.
Or Am I thinking of somewhere there?
Oh Wow.
Wow.
$199 flight to Billy's
$149.
It's very cheap.
It is cheap.
Where the fuck is believes?
It says that specific properties of the drugs that he was attempting to isolate.
This is all in the Gizmodo article by the way.
I take no credit for this.
Um,
the specific properties of the drugs he was attempting to isolate also fit in
well with what those closest to him have reported that he is an enthusiastic
amateur pharmacologist with a long standing interest in drugs that induce sexual
behavior in women.
Indeed,
former friends of McAfee have said he could be extremely persistent and devious
and trying to coerce women who rebuff his advantage,
his advances to have sex with him.
Okay.
With us.
See that's just like when you,
when you see an article like that,
it written about something like that.
Like that seems to me like you have to have examples.
You can't just say that because you can say anything about anybody.
I can say that about,
you know,
you,
I could say like,
you know,
Brian Red Ban has been known to be extremely vindictive and women who ignores
advances and he's an amateur pharmacologist.
But where's your,
you have to have evidence to say some creepy shit like that,
don't you?
Well,
I mean he did have a chemical lab in his house when they raided it didn't there.
But if he's telling the truth that he was using it to make an antiseptic,
a natural antiseptic,
I mean,
I don't know who the fuck knows what the grant does.
Who does that?
Oh No,
not me.
But whoever invented antiseptics in the first place.
I mean,
who,
who has a lab that does anything if you're living in the rain forest,
which,
uh,
I think believes in like a rain forest,
all of the medical,
uh,
like modern medical breakthroughs.
Not all of them,
but a big percentage of them come from plants that are discovered in remote rain
forest.
I mean,
he did say that he was just walking around and picking out plants by the creek
and stuff.
There's a lot of people that fucking trip on plants,
you know,
they,
they love botany.
You know,
Terence Mckenna was a botanist.
They,
I think there's a lot of people that become in love with the idea of these
different fascinating plants.
Plants are really,
I mean,
if we found them on other planets,
we'd be shitting her fucking pants.
There's so many weird plants on this planet.
You know,
somebody straight.
There's a a flower that just bloomed recently.
I guess it doesn't bloom very often,
but it's the world's largest flower.
She'd get a picture of it.
I think it's an Australia.
It looks crazy.
It looks like some fucking alien thing from a little shop of horrors,
one of those little,
uh,
things that eats people.
Yeah.
It doesn't even look real.
And apparently it's smells like rotting flesh.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Plants are creepy as fuck,
man.
There's plants that eat things.
There's plants that trick rats into fallen in them and then they close up on the
rats and digest them.
No,
that's not,
it is the world's largest flower blooms.
If he just,
uh,
just Google world's largest flower blooms.
Yeah.
That's not blooms
on yesterday.
Nope.
That's not it.
It was really three.
Sorry.
Yeah,
that was really recent.
Yes.
That's it.
Look at the size of that thing.
It's that,
it's,
it's Switzerland.
Look at the size of that thing.
It's insane.
Cause like corn on the cob cock.
Yeah.
It does look like a corn on the cob.
Exactly.
Look at the size of it though.
It's an amazing holy shit.
And it grows like a deck.
It's sprouts and the,
the,
the deck pops out and the flowers underneath that mean it is,
when I say huge,
I mean how many feet is that is?
Well,
it's taller about looks like 12 feet maybe.
At least.
Yeah.
It's,
its towering over these people that are looking at it.
Does it say there how it is a 2.27 meters tall.
Okay.
So it's only like six feet a meter.
Three feet,
right?
2.2 yeah,
I think a meter.
Three feet.
Wow.
Amazing though.
So it must be on a platform so it makes it look even bigger,
but it's God,
it's fucking incredible.
The variations to seven meters.
Oh,
did you ask Siri?
Siri doesn't know shit.
Watch Siri.
Fuck this up.
Looking like you confuse bitch.
This might answer your question.
It's,
yeah,
it's 7.4 feet.
Finally Siri,
Sherri got something right.
Siri's been upgraded a lot lately.
I don't know if you really,
you could even buy movie tickets now.
He'd just be like,
I want real estate's tickets now by them.
Do you have to have an APP that it connects you to do that?
I don't know.
Does it have to have your cell phone,
your credit card stored on your phone?
I don't know.
You don't know?
I haven't done it.
How do you know it works?
I just saw it on,
cause you're an apple fan boy
by the way.
Just to get that new phone soon.
Oh cool.
I got the first time I ever got one of those.
A hard drives to SSD hard drives.
That's the only way to go in the future.
Just they're beautiful 10 times faster
on a rendering audio that I'm doing on it
and they're supposed to be more,
um,
more reliable.
Look,
they don't break as easy.
I've had a bunch of hard drives fail.
Yeah.
Shit's annoying.
And all of a sudden your,
your,
your beach balls just spinning on your desktop and like the fuck's going on.
If there was a machine and you were held down and strapped in and uh,
they're the answer,
the real answer to this guy,
McAfee,
you know,
is he guilty or not guilty?
And if you had to choose one,
and if you choose wrong and he's black date goes shoved into your mouth and he
comes in you,
uh,
which one would you pick?
I don't think he killed anybody.
You don't think he killed anyway?
It might be wrong.
So that would be your answer,
not give it.
If I had to make an answer of not guilty or guilty,
I would say not guilty,
but I don't.
Um,
I don't have a,
you know,
I don't know.
It's a stupid answer.
I don't have any information.
I don't know,
like to be connected to yes or no is to me it seems a silly choice.
Like there's a lot of people that make choices about shit,
you know,
like whether someone was guilty or not guilty and they get all and Nancy grace
on things and you know,
and sometimes they're fucking wrong.
Like Nancy grace was with the Duke Lacrosse case,
you know,
there,
those guys were innocent and they,
there was a rape and Nancy grace like for days was on TV accusing them of doing
it.
I mean,
while they were set up,
they didn't do shit.
It was,
it was all false accusation and eventually the,
the charges were dropped,
but Nancy grace was committed to it on her show because it's salacious because
it's,
it looks like that's the,
that's a good thing to be upset about this.
Too much fuckery in this world.
Too much fuckery to know what,
what exactly what's going on.
Unless you were there.
You got to really look at all the parts and for this guy who the fuck knows
happened?
Who knows what he's doing?
If he really was doing that MDPV
and then somebody killed your dog and you're high on fucking boner.
Hold on
right there.
Okay.
If that guy really was doing MDPV and all those people on Gizmodo or telling the
truth,
or the guy,
uh,
about,
you know,
on Gizmodo is telling the truth,
but all the people you talked to,
then Dan,
the guy's a liar and everything he says has to be questioned.
Everything.
He says,
if he really never has done that mdpv right then,
you know,
then we could look at him and go,
wow,
maybe this guy's being set up,
but if he has done it and he lied about that just on the show,
if he told that false version of himself for any reason.
Yeah.
You know,
and you've got to say you can't trust them the way he doesn't want to leave.
Like,
no,
I will not pay to like he's got this,
you know,
edge to them where it makes me think that if he was high on some kind of fucking
drug where whatever,
and somebody killed your dogs,
you know,
and you're a guy that has a machine gun and,
and,
and you don't like shirts much and you're high on this shit.
I could see him just raging going like,
no,
you don't know who you fuck with.
You know?
Maybe,
but who knows if he's,
if he's telling the truth,
then I don't know.
Hmm.
Yeah.
It's killing your dogs.
It makes,
will make people rage.
That's like a child.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Who knows?
If I had to guess though,
I would guess a,
apparently he knew a lot of bad people down there.
He hung out with a lot of gangsters and believes,
which is probably a smart move your rich guy,
surround yourself with uh,
you know,
thug life
because it seemed like he would hang out with thugs.
He seems like would hang on the yoga dude's,
well,
at least in that one photo that we were showing during the thing,
but then that other fully where he has the gun,
he kind of looks like,
okay,
that guy is craziness.
I bet he would have been a fun dude to hang around with before all this shit
with Doug.
But he's shy,
but he still is.
But who knows,
man.
I want to know what this a airplane thing is.
Uh,
that looks like a look like a motorcycle.
Is that what he said?
Like a little like a kite.
What does it,
what the fuck did he call it?
Mcafee.
Mcafee plane.
But yeah,
no,
don't look upset.
Hmm.
Airplane.
Okay.
Accident it.
Done.
It's,
um,
it sounds like,
like wild,
nutty,
fun to get on some kind of a fucking motorcycle like kite.
Yeah.
Or I wouldn't do it
with you.
Yeah.
What is it?
I wonder what the fuck it is.
Hmm.
Yeah.
Plagued by lawsuits.
Even like way before this in 2010,
it talked about him a hiding and Billy's,
and now he hopes to give something back by deriving antibiotics from plants in
Belize.
Seems like it's like,
he's definitely a dude who likes attention.
I like,
it was pretty easy to get him to come on the podcast and talk.
There must be part of him that's enjoying a little bit of this notoriety he's
experiencing here or he just wants to make us and everybody know about it.
Kind of like a news type thing because you know,
in the more people know about it,
if he does get caught,
people are going to like be like,
oh yeah,
no doubt.
No doubt that too.
No doubt.
That to the whole thing is,
I mean the fact that he wouldn't see how it being a personality piece would lead
people to um,
pay more attention to it.
Smiling with this fucking gun in his hand,
looking straight at the camera.
By the way.
It's not,
it's not just one photo of him like that.
If you look at the photos of him online,
like the first three,
if you look under his McAfee photo images,
the first three are of him topless with guns
is quite a character though.
Man.
I would've loved to have hung out with him before all this.
It seems like a fun guy to talk to.
I bet you get a little drunk with him.
He's got some great stories.
Okay.
W you know,
that's that thing that people talk about,
like doing that.
Go down to a small island country somewhere and just live out my life.
She's riding my boat around and live in right by the water.
But how many people actually fucking do that?
Okay,
very few.
You have to be some special kind of weird motherfucker to actually go through
with that.
Become an ex pat and just kick back on the beach and not even know people there.
I Dunno.
It's kind of cool out.
We got to talk to them.
Yeah,
it was one of the things that I was saying yesterday when we were talking to a
Shane Smith,
like one of the selfish reasons for starting this podcast is I want to have
conversations with these people.
I want to have conversations with guys like Dave Asprey.
I can't just get them to have a conversation with me,
you know,
but to have a conversation where you broadcast broadcasted all of a sudden it's,
fairly easy to get ahold of people.
It seems like that would be the opposite.
Like people would be less likely to talk to you for hours on end if they knew it
was being broadcast.
But actually that's not the case.
Dennis Mckenna is coming on the podcast soon.
The brother of a Terence Mckenna,
he's got a book out about,
uh,
his,
time with his,
uh,
with his brother.
And,
uh,
by all accounts,
it's pretty bad ass book.
And we'll probably have a,
Mitch Schultz will be joining him who is the producer of Dmt,
the spirit molecule.
So we'll talk science psychedelic compounds and uh,
his brother,
the great Terence Mckenna and Dennis is a fascinating guy to,
um,
he had,
uh,
well I don't even want to tell the story,
but uh,
there's
uh,
some great accounts of his own psychedelic experiences that maybe he'll get
into.
He had some fairly psychotic episode where I don't think he,
uh,
I think he lost his sanity for a couple of weeks off a DMT?
No,
for mushrooms in the Amazon.
Yeah.
It's supposed to be a pretty intense story.
Hopefully he'll tell it to us.
Good.
Terrance talked about it in depth in some of his books.
Um,
and then,
uh,
we've got Duncan Trussell uh,
tomorrow and um,
Eddie Bravo on Thursday and the next to,
hopefully it will be in the new studio.
If we could figure out a way to work out that fucking shitbag Internet
connection,
you would think that in this day and age there would be more options that every
building there is apps.
I bet you there is options there.
I think.
I think I'm going to have to get like a t three lines stalls need to call Time
Warner or the other one.
Hello My,
my business manager saying that they're,
they're having a hard time falling.
Finding
business manager also acts a Dso got upso well they got me DSL because that was
the only option available.
But that's,
you can't even do it studio on Dsl.
He,
I mean he should be like a,
hey look,
he doesn't know what it's dude,
you know and tails.
How did I know?
How the fuck are they supposed to know this guy said no.
Well how was she sells the most?
But if you say a studio,
if it's the fastest
Internet you have,
they'll go,
okay,
we'll take it and then you get it and it sucks the fat Dick.
You don't know until you try it.
Like most people have no idea.
Like I didn't know it wouldn't be adequate if you said three megabytes download,
I'd be like,
all right,
that sounds good.
Go that.
That's like double a t one line.
A T one is like 1.5 megawatt.
So we have 120 gig download here.
And you had a three?
Yeah,
our upload here is I think 40 up make upload.
You had
less than one.
Less than one.
Yeah.
That's wack.
Weak ass pictures.
You got to fix it at t and t Uverse get a fat pipe to my office or heads will
roll.
No,
actually I'll just cancel.
I need to find out what all the options are as far as like,
like dedicated lines.
Like when they do an ISD n line,
when someone has to uh,
like do the radio.
I know like people have radio studios,
they have like a dedicated line.
I'm pretty sure that kind of Shit's not as good as,
no,
it's,
it's terrible.
But I'm saying I wonder if they can do that with like a t one or a t three and
not a t one.
Two one's not good enough,
but like a t three line or something.
Just the fiber.
That's all you need.
They don't have it though.
They have cable or not.
Will Not in my area,
not in the area of my offices.
My office is,
he doesn't.
No one does.
How do you know that?
Because they've looked,
they just sent me an email explaining all the different shit that they don't
have.
No,
no cable known this so that they don't expect people to want like anything
better than this.
In those areas.
Most people,
they're regular businesses is just involves.
So you're saying that that there for sure there's no cable or there's no fiber
through eight it's time Warner or any of the other companies.
Tom Warmer where time Warner or a and t or any,
yeah.
No,
it's not charter.
No.
Those fucks.
That seems impossible.
It seems like it.
But it's true.
If that's true,
you're screwed.
I'm fucked.
But cellular four g cellular is not good enough.
And honey would take it before Jan left at cell phone,
Ladies and gentlemen out there listening,
surely you must have some sort of a fucking solution.
Tech.
I can't,
Shit.
That would suck.
That was the one thing I told you I was like,
before you get it,
make sure they have fascinating.
And that's the most important thing.
Yep.
They said they did those Fox,
we'll work it out.
Freaks.
We'll work it out.
Oh my God.
I don't believe Your Business Manager.
It's not their fault.
I don't believe it.
No,
I don't believe him.
You don't have,
I don't believe.
I believe that there's,
well,
we'll get off the phone and we'll figure it out.
Okay.
Um,
we'll get off to the line.
Anything else you want to add with this?
This weekend we're going to be in Austin,
Texas.
That should be a fucking blast.
It's a,
a quick weekend in and out.
You freaks.
Um,
and then next weekend I am uh,
the,
the following weekend we're in Seattle,
uh,
at the,
what the fuck is the name of the comedy club?
The polar live,
that's it.
It's in Bellevue,
Washington.
I emailed you about that.
That you put that on the tall.
I'd have to check my email check emails,
son.
I sub check.
Do you check your email?
I'm starting not to check my email now.
Like voicemail died recently for me.
I don't like or regular mail.
I don't do regular mail anymore.
Voicemails.
I don't like listening to voicemails now.
Like if I have a voicemail on my phone,
I don't even look at it.
And now recently email,
I just,
I'm like giving up.
Like,
I don't know,
man.
I,
I like email.
It's too much.
It is too much though.
After a while it gets crazy.
You,
uh,
so much shit.
Too much.
I don't know.
Yeah,
no,
I know what you're talking about ma'am.
Um,
it's,
it's just overwhelming how much shit you can get thrown at you that you have to
pay attention to them.
That was one of the best things about going camping is that for five days,
no phone calls,
no emails,
no nothing.
You know?
Yeah.
It's one of the nicest things that have like a little break,
a little reset.
Like I actually looked forward to getting emails after that.
My new favorite thing on the phone,
I don't know if you've used this on the iPhone,
is the a do not disturb a,
so at night you just click on this do not disturb button.
No phone calls,
no texts,
but you still have like Internet,
you know,
and shit like that.
But it's just because that would be getting phone calls like,
Oh set my uh,
alarm to wake me up and they don't get a phone call at like two in the morning,
you know?
And I'm like,
Oh,
what the fuck?
And it will wake me up or somebody will send me a stupid text,
you know,
at six in the morning.
So that's what do not disturb us.
Yeah.
Just turns everything off.
But it's,
everything's still comes in so it's not like you have it on airplane mode.
Right.
Because it doesn't ever visit any warnings.
It doesn't,
yeah.
Just turns all that shit off.
Does it still light up?
Like does it get brighter?
Um,
I think it just,
it depends on,
you'd see I have all text messages turned off all notifications,
turned off on my phone,
everything turned off on my phone.
Now,
I don't even like a window popping up cause I was just getting like,
you know,
too in too much trouble when I was a dating,
you know like there'll be like a text that pop up like,
Hey,
what are you doing tonight honey in and then right,
oh who,
who is this right?
Is this getting me in too much trouble?
So do not disturb is a way out of that.
Yeah.
Well I just turned off all notifications.
So like if I get a check your fucking phone off,
I know I'm about to or are you,
are you getting that way at all?
Like I'm,
I'm starting to like,
I don't want,
like I'm turning into Joey d is like,
I'm going backwards.
I want to get just a pager.
Well just something to be said for not,
you know,
when you're constantly interacting with people all day long,
you have no time to reflect.
Really trying to think for yourself.
Right?
You just constantly dealing with other people's requests for,
you know,
hey,
I've got a question.
Hey,
what's up?
what's going on?
What are you doing?
Do you want to do this?
You want to do that?
What's the plan?
And constantly,
can you call me?
I got this going on and after a while it's like you,
you,
if you're in the loop of communicating with a bunch of different people all the
time,
you're constantly responding to things.
Yes.
Text messages.
Like sometimes I'll get in this like text message thing where like three dudes
are texting me at the same time.
And so like you're texting them trying to answer questions or talk to him about
shit and it's like,
and then another one comes in from the other guy and then you hit that and like
how many times do you banter back and forth too?
And it's with school.
Girls are brutal.
Yeah.
If you got in a fight with a girl
over a text message and writing paragraph after paragraph
and you have to like respond to it,
you have to like go back and read and write and then when you're done she has
another paragraph we loaded and ready.
Yeah.
At least you could do is email me your crazy fish.
Writing in a text form is rude and you know,
and by the way,
that's what you're doing for the next few hours.
Good luck with that.
Yeah.
You know,
instead of having a phone call or a meeting person,
the person talking this shit out.
Oh my God.
You said being with me.
Huh?
Drama for your Mama.
Yeah.
There's gotta be a way out of this prime gotta be a way to positive beliefs,
beliefs.
Well the website shows a lot of white people holding hands.
Perfect.
That's what I want to do.
I want to hold hands with white people and walk on the beach and no one I have
no shoes on and be relaxed enough to be staring at the water through my toes
with my 17 year old Hadi.
Yeah.
While I'm bath salts,
allegedly according to Gizmodo,
I,
I feel like I trust John McAfee.
How about that?
Had a conversation with him.
He was a hell of a nice guy.
I detected no hint of bath salts in our conversation.
Yeah.
Shit felt legit.
I felt like he was really there with me.
And you know why he's got a good point about those cops making a dollar an hour.
Maybe if someone paid him $20 now they wouldn't have shot that guy 14 times in a
van.
He's just fucking pay all the cops.
It's just,
well I think he tried to do that.
I think he had his own sort of an army and I think he had,
uh,
and that's,
you know,
one of the things they tried to stop compounds and governments before they
start.
So when you start seeing a dude accumulate dogs and guns and you want to move
in,
send a fucking sniff troop into the math lab,
see what's being cooked up,
their legal or illegal.
All right.
But this MDPV stuff,
not legal in America anymore,
but Leah Lind believes,
although it doesn't matter because that's not what he was doing,
right?
No,
he's researching.
Yeah.
So this,
um,
they have a picture of this,
this plane thing.
It's pretty crazy.
It really does look like a,
um,
like a,
like a motorcycle with a kite on the top of it.
And his nephew a dive in this thing with a 61 year old passenger.
Hmm.
They had been flying in clean,
smooth air with plenty of altitude.
Mcafee told me when suddenly they went into a spiral dive and crash into the
ground.
The terrain was so rugged that the sheriff's deputies took a helicopter to the
top of the ridge and hiked down to retrieve the bodies leaving the records where
it lay.
Wow.
Sounds like it's dangerous as fuck,
but it's dangerous as fuck to do a lot of shit.
Skydiving's dangerous as fuck those bodysuits.
Have you ever seen that video where the guy's on a,
that wingsuit and he crashes?
Yeah.
Ooh,
that looks horrifying.
It's wings in,
it's,
that guy was fine with that guy is fucked up too.
I mean,
I think he broke like every bone in his body.
He lived.
But you're,
you're,
you're flying.
You know like,
who knows?
Like it's like a hundred miles an hour or sometimes it's pretty crazy how fast
those things go.
And you clip the ground and you just go from Matt Tumble.
But that's legal.
Can't see anything.
Anybody for that.
Can't sue anybody for hand gliding,
I don't think.
Unless you rent a fucking hang glide and it snaps in half,
then maybe your family can sue the rental company for not maintaining it.
But if you die in a hang gliding accident because of some crazy wind,
you know,
situation,
you're lucky you're not addicted to video games anymore because I got something
that you would,
you'd go crazy on what?
It's a suitcase.
And when you open it up and it's travel approved,
when you open it up,
there's a 19 inch monitor,
a sound system.
There's lights,
you put your x box and there your ps three and the star wars Xbox.
But any it just try,
you travel with it.
The sound is loud.
It's,
it's got light like blue lights all around it.
So at night it's glows and it's 10 80 P it's a games,
uh,
Feliks incredible.
What is it called?
It's a games a all in one.
I have a youtube video of it.
See the problem with all that
shit is that if you're going to play a fucking game,
he should have the most accurate input devices.
And when you're playing games and you have
works for the games that you're used to playing.
Yeah,
but,
but see these games are designed not for mouse and keyboard.
They're designed for the controller,
but you don't get as much accuracy.
Why would you not want a mouse and a keyboard once you play with a mouse and a
keyboard.
Oh,
you have it there.
Is that it?
Yeah.
This is it right here.
They send you one of these things?
No,
I bought it.
I bought it for the studio because we do so many video game podcast at death
squad that I was like,
we should have a unit here so we can play video games and show people you have
it here right now.
No,
I didn't bring it today.
What the fuck?
It was a video of you playing with it.
So,
um,
how many games did you play on this?
I've only been playing call of duty and I haven't even been doing playing much
because I've been busy.
And how's it look?
It's awesome.
It looks great.
It's great.
It's got two headphone jacks in the front of it.
So you can,
you know,
play online and you know,
have your own headphones plugged in and uh,
it's,
it's great that it has an htmi port in it.
So like if you wanted to,
you can also hook like a ps three or a Nintendo wi or whatever.
Uh,
you could hook it up to a television.
Yeah.
And they have a 15 inch version,
uh,
that they sell,
like at best buy and stuff.
This is the third new 19 inch Halos special edition version is the first time
they have 19 inch monitor in it,
stuff like that.
But I have a video showing it.
If you go to youtube.com backslash,
let's find Jesus and let's find Jesus is just all my tech review shit.
Do you know I'll do the team phone surveys.
Does anybody ever get pissed at your youtube name?
Let's find Jesus.
No,
but I think there were more pissed at,
let's find jesus.com.
Why?
Because it was a website that's a website that sells a religious things that I
made a long time ago when me and McAfee's to troll people.
Let's find jesus.com does it sell things?
Yeah.
Like Jesus his hair.
Jesus's hair from the barber shop.
This is black.
Jesus.
Uh,
Jesus stealing a baby drawing that it's a,
it's a painting of Jesus is stealing a baby.
No,
I've never sold one actually,
but it's been on.
Oh,
they actually for sale though.
I it somebody bought it.
Oh No,
they're not for sale.
No.
Fuck you don't say that as the mix CD.
Jesus has mixed CD.
A bunch of songs that I wrote about
time ago about Jesus and Mary and Noah.
Is this?
No.
Oh,
this is uh,
this is,
uh,
don't forget to bring the love birds on the boat.
Noah for Mary.
Oh,
and there's a lot,
like there's a remix,
there's tons of real next version or other songs or is that same song?
It's remix versions of that same theme.
Yeah.
Birds,
it says to,
you know,
by the way,
that's not any more ridiculous than any of the songs I hear on one of those
serious XF Xm,
like the coffee house.
Oh,
right,
right.
No,
half of those fucking really emo songs.
Check this out.
This is a,
another thing I just reviewed a,
this is a biologic tech,
uh,
Wifi,
um,
webcam.
And what it does is it connects to your wifi network and then you have a
wireless Webcam and it has a button on it that you push that automatically
starts streaming the use stream.
So you stream has partnered with these guys,
I guess if somehow,
but it's,
it's like this is,
it has a,
uh,
a tripod with a magnet on it so you can rotate it all around,
which is,
it's also a case,
but it's just a wireless web cam.
So if you're on the same wifi network,
if you're on a wifi network,
you can carry this whole thing around your whole house and you have a wireless,
a Webcam,
and it's got like a three hour battery life.
Does it have an a?
I'm a microphone.
It's got a microphone.
It's got a light on the front of it.
It's,
it's,
it's carrying case,
which I'm showing right now.
Uh,
it,
you take it out and it makes,
it's a doubles as a tripod and uh,
it also has a magnet on it.
So the magnet is for the tilting and stuff like that.
You could also has a hook so you can screw it onto a tripod and it's got really
good quality.
It's a HD Webcam.
That's amazing.
What is it called?
Uh,
it's the Logitech,
a broadcast or Wifi and it's,
you know,
it's Super Mac friendly.
It's actually designed more for Mac.
Almost a piece socket windows.
Yeah.
And so I have a video.
So on the,
let's find Jesus Youtube Channel.
Dude,
that sounds like something we need to get ahold of.
I have one right there.
We need to use that shit.
Well I think for what we do it wouldn't really benefit.
I know now I'm still playing with it cause we already have,
we have video cameras and mixers here,
so yeah,
but not here.
I mean like at shows.
Oh yeah.
For shows if we can get on the wifi network or bring a hot spot maybe.
Yeah,
yeah.
We should start doing that.
Maybe we should do that this weekend in Austin.
They,
we should broadcast and Oscar from the green room before the show.
It's going to you,
me and Dunkin and a Aubrey from ana.com.
Yeah.
Oh snap.
We're going to have a good time.
Yes.
Oh,
snappy dirty bitches.
I forgot that.
We're in Austin this weekend,
man.
Saturday night.
Well I forgot Aubrey was,
he lived there.
Yeah.
That's cool.
Yeah,
we're going to have a good fucking time.
Yeah.
And then we got to go to this barbecue place that everybody waits in line all
day for supposed to be ridiculous.
Abi said they would hire someone to go wait in line.
But the problem with that is,
and you don't get it fresh,
you want to get it like right as it comes off the grill.
The only way to do that as you have to wait in line for like an hour and a half.
Oh fuck that.
No,
I don't want that crazy way.
Let's go eat her own this and make our own.
No,
you don't know what you're doing.
I don't care.
Your barbecue and still waiting an hour and a half are from barbecue.
It's supposed to be unbelievable.
Ari Shaffir said it was so good after you waited in line,
an hour and a half,
it was
worth it.
Anything is good.
If you wait in line for an hour and a half.
That's why anytime you,
oh,
your wife cooks for you,
it's always good because you had to sit there and wait two hours instead of two
minutes for putting a lien pocket in the microwave.
You were like,
all right,
I just had to sit here and smell the whole cooking process of the food.
Of course I'm going to love your food.
I don't know what I'm talking about about yeah,
definitely.
Of course.
Poor fool.
Uh,
so,
uh,
we'll see you guys tomorrow.
We have nothing else to say to each other.
We will be doing a,
a,
a just Brian and Joe only podcasts though to celebrate our 300th podcast.
I think we've done that with every 100,
right?
Everyone.
Oh No.
We tried to do one with dunk and then we did one with Duncan last time.
Yeah.
Um,
but the um,
the 100th and now the 300th,
it's kind of crazy.
This is our third year doing this,
this month.
Next month.
Uh,
Mark's our third year of doing this podcast.
Yeah,
it's crazy.
Ridiculous.
[inaudible] how the fuck that happened?
Time just flew up.
Remember when you were like back in the day.
We would make fun of December 21st,
2012 dudes can be the underworld.
Cause it didn't seem like it was real.
It didn't seem like that date was ever going to come.
That shits this month,
son.
It's almost December 1st,
December 1st on Saturday,
20 days later.
End of the Mayan calendar.
Are you ready?
You ain't shit.
You ain't ready.
You're not ready for doomsday.
You Ain't a prepper.
Did you watch prepping?
You ever watch that day prepping?
No.
It's a good shot of watch.
It's one of my new things.
I watched these nutty bitches canning peaches and fucking stuffing them under
their bed.
One Guy,
he shot his thumb.
He had a fucking his,
his gun misfired and it's to stumps.
Started bleeding and he fainted.
Mike,
you fucking pussy.
You think you're going to last through the fucking apocalypse and you can't even
deal with a little blood loss.
You faint like a bitch,
cause your thumbs bleeding.
How dare you,
how dare you be on Doomsday preppers with that bitch ass attitude.
There was one couple that was really religious and they were buying a lot of
alcohol and like,
we don't even drink alcohol,
but we're going to need it for bartering.
And also would construct Molotov cocktails and case were attacked.
And so then they were practicing with the Molotov cocktails.
Like they uh,
had like this,
uh,
these rocks and they would,
light the fucking,
the thing you know when a Molotov cocktail is folks,
it's the take a thing of high proof alcohol and you stuff like a rag in it and
get it all wet with the alcohol and then you light the rag and throw it and
explodes and flames.
So he's fucking dumb.
He's just standing there throwing glasses of vodka at the rocks and burst them
into flame view.
This is a good weapon.
Meanwhile,
they have fucking guns.
They have like huge caches of guns,
huge safes filled with machine guns.
They have like ankle holsters on and they'll lose was right next to my dick or
keep it going next to my deck on next to my ankle.
Like they,
they're like completely prepped and every month they go to the supermarket and
they go to like Costco's and places like that and stock up on supplies so that
can be better prepared.
Like they have a budget of every month
where they'll buy like guns and bullets and water and fucking bananas.
Man.
Bananas to watch when the apocalypse comes.
You've got to really,
you've got to really wonder whether or not you want to make it through.
Someone had to do that in the past because everything was the apocalypse when we
were monkeys.
Okay.
Every day was the apocalypse.
You know,
you had to fucking go out and scrounge for food.
There was no supermarkets,
there's no internet,
there's no electricity.
It's essentially mad.
Max was way better than the way the monkeys lived.
Least Mad Max had a car.
Okay.
The apocalypse,
you know,
being like that road warrior type scenario,
that ain't shit compared to what it definitely used to be.
And somebody had to get through that to get to here.
They had to get through that to get to here.
But the problem is once you're already here,
fairly tough to go back to caveman days.
Very tough to scrounge out of living,
eating dead people that you find under a fucking overpass cause that's the only
meat he can bring home to your family.
Jesus Christ.
You got to,
you got to wonder whether or not you want to make it through that.
Like what's the end game and that sort of scenario.
If an asteroid hits you really want it to hit you like it just land right on.
Yen's fucking let's try this again.
Right?
What are you doing over there?
Surfing the web.
No,
I'm looking,
I just reading that pour or a pour.
The porn industry is uh,
suing Verizon for protecting pirates and I was just like,
wow.
Verizon standing up for the pirates.
That's crazy.
Huh?
The porn industry is a PR.
What are they saying that people are stealing them like on bit torrent and stuff
like that.
Stealing their videos.
They're saying that Verizon has refusing to comply with court ordered subpoenas
and the porn studio c it is more than a,
you were there just the,
they just want the names of people that are torrenting as shit and for I guess
for reasons not playing along.
That's funny because they play on along with the record industry.
Right.
Uh,
does Verizon play along with them?
I don't know.
I mean some people don't,
some people send out messages but they won't.
Um,
they won't actively see.
I don't just don't listen to hot.
Not a lot for them.
You know,
the Internet companies and going after people that are pirates,
it's almost like,
yeah,
you gotta you gotta figure that shit out on your own.
Cause they're in the business of providing Internet service.
And one of the things that people want to do with that insurance services
download shit,
you know,
for you to like start peering into what they're downloading.
And you know that a mega upload scenario,
you know what's going on with that,
that that Guy kim.com who said,
uh,
he was like famous in the early days of the Internet.
It used to be a hacker and a then became a computer security is expert and
apparently made a fuck load of money and he takes all these,
used to have this blog and he takes all these crazy pictures of him in front of
his yacht and you know,
chilling in Brazil and flying in private jet to this
place and he's got this ridiculous mansion house where he lives in,
in New Zealand and he's embroiled in this huge,
uh,
legal battle because of mega upload.com which was his,
a website that was accused of,
uh,
hosting pirated material.
And apparently the,
the,
the government,
like they,
they like according to Kim Dotcom,
like he complied with every request the government have for taking things down
and that they actually asked him to not take these certain files down.
And those are the ones that they wind up charging him for.
Cause they were,
you know,
they want asked him to not do it because they were trying to track it or
something like that.
So He's saying that they acted in bad faith in,
in organizing their,
their evidence against him is,
I,
as I understand it,
I might have fucked that,
that argument up,
but it's kind of interesting that this,
uh,
this guy is like the super rich geek who is trying to keep file sharing alive
and keep these upload sites alive and now he's a making one where everyone else
can contribute,
download that you can contribute bandwidth and storage.
So somehow or another end,
they're offering a one click encryption on the fly for free for all data.
So it's a,
it's really going to be interesting to see where this goes because if this guy
can figure out how,
how to do that,
um,
you know,
what,
what can these,
uh,
record industry people and what can these movie industry people do about that?
Because what he's saying is that there's,
um,
there's data on his site that shows that when mega upload was,
was a shutdown,
that it actually hurt box office numbers.
That it doesn't hurt movie like huge blockbuster movies like,
you know,
mission impossible type shit.
It doesn't hurt them,
but it hurts the box offices of more obscure movies who would be heard about and
transferred and uh,
and,
and talked about through the Internet and that people would hear about it
because of other people downloading them.
And that would actually cause more people to go out and buy it and see it,
which is,
you know,
sort of the,
that's the attitude that most comics take is that having anything of yours
that's out on the Internet,
it's the,
the more that's out there,
the better because then people will hear about you and there'll be able to uh,
go out and get your stuff.
That's why very few comics remove like mp3s for copyright violation.
It's like they're happy if anybody's listening because then more people listen
to the your future shit.
Yeah.
It's an interesting argument,
you know,
as far as what's copywritten and what's not and what hurts and what doesn't.
When someone's got a fucking movie theater in their house though,
that's when shit hurts.
Like you have a,
you have essentially have a movie theater in your house.
Yeah.
My New Shit is a movie theater in my house.
I've been watching so much shit on that thing and like I could see it being like
I saw a wreck it Ralph the other day and I went to one of those movie theaters
where like it was in a small room where the,
the,
the screen was about the same size as that.
The screen that now I have in my house,
I just take,
took one wall of my living room and pretty much made it a movie theater screen.
And the projectors are so good nowadays that,
that they're HD that it,
it's like you don't need,
uh,
this,
this projector screen was $200.
The projector with $700 and that right there is better.
I don't have any reason to go to a movie theater now.
Yeah,
if you could just get the movies directly.
What,
why can't they do that?
Why can't they just charge?
Like how about I iTunes,
you know,
do it through them.
Think about this.
Like if you go to the movies,
like how much does it cost to go to the movies?
It's like 10 bucks an hour.
So that's like 13 bucks there.
10 Bucks.
Where are you gonna charge me?
50.
Yeah,
they charged me 50,
so I can watch it with the whole family.
Right.
Charge me 50 bucks.
Well they,
they do that kind of like,
like,
uh,
bobcat's movies and,
and Kevin Smith's movie,
right state.
You,
you could,
uh,
get the odd before it even came out in movie theaters.
Yeah.
Well,
Kevin Smith,
it was beautiful.
Yeah.
That was the right way to do it.
That's very smart.
You know,
he's a aware of his sort of,
uh,
his community.
You know,
he can,
he can do something like that.
I hope he made money off that.
Oh,
of course he did.
It's good fucking movie.
Yeah,
it's a good fucking movie.
That movie was really well done.
And a Stephen King or a Steve route rather was amazing in it.
He was,
he's amazing in that boardwalk empire.
Just started watching that dude that shows fucking,
that's chose good dude.
Yeah.
There's too many God damn good shows.
Everybody's like,
you gotta Watch mad men.
Fuck you.
I do.
Why?
I do want to watch madmen.
That's on my list of things.
A little watch mad men just for that girl with the big tits and she had some big
too.
Those are all totally,
she's a real woman,
Huh?
Yeah.
That's rare that you see like a big voluptuous,
sexy plumped one.
The one with the red head.
Yes.
She's plump as fuck.
Just one up.
Yeah.
There you go.
Tell me.
Those are redonkulous,
right?
Yeah.
That's a,
is that what women ever looked like?
No.
You can't say that.
That's a rare specimen.
You can't call claim that.
That's how they,
that's how they all looked like in the 20s but you can't that show breaking bad.
You know which game of Thrones coming back?
Walking dead,
walking dead.
I keep hearing that too.
That's a problem.
Walking dead.
Only first couple episodes.
It was good,
but dude,
there's not that much time.
Oh,
that's the other thing.
I started watching his fucking homeland.
I started that with season one do.
That's good.
That shows good.
It's not what I thought it was either.
I thought it was like CSI type.
She's at the titanic bitch girl,
Claire Danes.
No,
no,
no.
I think you're thinking of a different girl.
I think so.
Yeah.
Think what is her name?
Is that her name?
Claire Danes.
Claire Danes is the titanic girl.
I thought she was in that or maybe I'm thinking of somebody else.
I don't think Claire Danes is a titanic girl.
The titanic girl was a little plumper.
No,
that's Claire Danes.
You know.
Are you sure?
Titanic?
Uh,
yeah.
Let's see.
Yep.
No,
no,
no.
Yeah.
No,
I don't think so.
Kate Winslet.
Yes.
There you go.
Claire Danes.
Just the one who was in this fucking this new show though.
She Claire Danes.
I was thinking of Romeo and Juliet.
She was in Clara dance with Leonardo Dicaprio thing.
It was a good movie back in the day.
Yeah.
She's been in a bunch of movies.
She's good man.
She,
she plays a good,
crazy bitch too.
She's in les Miserables wheels.
I say that lays and misery.
Les Miserables,
she was in that,
she's a serious actress that,
uh,
she's good at homeland.
It's good.
Fuck a trail dude.
Disturbing though.
It makes you wonder,
but how much of this is ripped from the headlines based on a true story,
but he,
uh,
that guy's a bad ass actor.
Who the fuck he is?
Who plays the other guy?
Um,
whatever,
whatever.
And again,
should we bring this bitch home?
That's why it's coming to San Diego.
12,
12.
Who,
who are these people?
I don't know yet.
I know as your coming here,
Sarah Tiana is going to be on there.
Tony Hinchcliffe.
You know there's been a few other people that said that they want to come by.
I haven't really,
I'm reschedule it this week.
December 12th is still a couple of weeks away.
So what you need to do is just prepare yourself for that night.
Keep checking Twitter.
We will build the anticipation.
Yes.
Hopefully I can make it down there for that one.
Uh,
I yeah,
it's a great round.
Yeah.
I got a lot of shit going on right now.
There's a,
well,
I can't really talk about them in the air.
Good stuff though,
folks.
Um,
so this weekend,
that's it.
Moody Theater,
Austin,
Texas.
Next week,
um,
Paul or live in Bellevue,
Washington with powerful Sam Tripoli.
And then,
um,
the Wiltern theater,
December 21st,
2012,
the end of the world show with honey,
honey,
Doug,
Stan hope,
Joey motherfucking Diaz and Wa and uh,
that should be pretty crazy.
That's going to be a fun show and no,
the f the world's not gonna end.
Relax.
We're going to be fine.
Hopefully.
Who knows?
It might not be real.
My now be real.
Right Brian?
I feel like it's not real.
It's definitely not real simulation theory.
You are,
you're 100% on board now.
Yeah.
Super simulation theory.
What became,
what was the tipping point that really made you think this to this world's not
real?
Well,
if you think of it as if it is a simulation theory and then you start going,
all right,
this is hilarious.
You know,
somewhere I'm playing on an iPhone 77 and this is just like,
because there's just too many things that are like,
all right,
that's ridiculous that that just happened.
That's ridiculous that that just happened.
I think so.
I,
I'm,
I don't believe in it,
but I'm acting like I do believe in it.
And just,
just looking at life through that,
that perspective.
And it really does seem,
if you just spend like the next week acting like everything's a simulation,
like don't jump in front of building the art cars or buildings.
You could jump in front of buildings but don't jump in front of cars.
But if you think of it as it's a simulation,
it's ridiculous.
And then so what I've been also adding to it that Asians are the ones that are
like kind of babysitting us in the Sim simulation.
So if you,
if you talk about the simulation too much,
you'll see you're out of nowhere in Asian will come around the corner and just
stare at you like,
oh,
wait a minute.
That's why are the Asians,
I don't know.
The Asians aliens.
Huh?
Do you think Asians are alien?
I think Asians are like,
are like the babysitters that lessen the simulation.
I think you gotta be very careful when talking about any race.
Isn't it funny like Asian people can get pissed off at that,
that you'd be like,
what the fuck do you know?
Yeah.
Because their,
their security,
they're mad.
You're not supposed to talk about this simulation.
Is that what it is or is it,
you're not supposed to talk about any,
you're not supposed to talk about any race at all.
All right.
Even,
you know,
even if you're saying positive things,
like the aliens might be more advanced than us and the,
you know,
they,
they have more uh,
alien DNA in Asian people.
Like you can't say that cause that's making Asian people better,
but they'll still get upset.
Like you're not even allowed to talk about them.
People are so fucking sensitive.
Brian,
I had something weird happened to me the other day.
I have you ever had,
were like,
I was laying down,
you might have this in the isolation tank,
but maybe I was laying down and I had my eyes closed and I was looking at the
images in my,
I like on my eyelids and you know,
sometimes you see little things floating around.
Sometimes you might see like little things moving and stuff,
but I had full on motion video,
like a person talking somewhere like to somebody else,
like full on like movement,
like a hundred frames per second.
Like it was like I was watching somebody talk.
It wasn't a memory because of memory you think of something and you're like,
oh yeah,
we were sitting there and then we were talking.
This was actually watching somebody talk like in full video,
but it was like just the outline in my eyelid.
I found that trippy
so
I found that trippy.
Well,
I mean are you saying you were hallucinating?
I was [inaudible] your eyes closed but it was,
it was like always wa it wasn't like the guy was tripping and melting and
turning into a snake or anything.
It was like somebody just sitting there having a conversation with somebody.
But it was full motion.
Like as if it was our was watching somebody,
like if I were to open my eyes and it was somebody standing there doing it and
then I'd be like,
okay,
that makes sense.
But there was no one there and it was like,
you don't think like,
like I don't dream like that.
I don't like if I think about somebody you know running,
I can kind of see them running in my head,
but this was like full on motion.
Like it was weird.
You've done enough drug so you've broken your brain.
Okay maybe that's it.
Is that possible?
Or I was somehow spying on a different part in the world of the simulation I was
hacking through the firewalls.
That could be it too.
You never will.
Yeah.
You have to figure out like what real is and what's not real.
Right.
What if you know,
they were like the reality that we exist in,
you know the one of the more attractive parts of the simulation theory thing is
that I do think that thoughts and I do think that a intention can move life in a
certain way.
I think it's flexible.
I think the world that we live in is a lot more flexible and then we'd like to
thank and our rigid interpretation of things as being like the only things that
are real or things you can weigh or measure and knock on.
I don't think so man.
I think there's some,
uh,
some fucking weirdness to it all.
So the idea of a simulation theory sorta comes into play it because there's
certain things that do get manifested with the mind.
There's certain people that sorta almost are like extras in a movie and there's
certain events that almost are like peripheral non events that you could choose
to pay attention to,
are not paying attention to in the background,
but your,
your main focus,
your,
your life,
the things that that's going on in your world.
You have a little bit of control over it.
You got a little bit of wiggle room there.
It's not as simple as,
you know,
uh,
drive one mile and you're a mile away from where you wear it.
It.
It has to do more with what,
what,
where you are is in your head a little bit and where you're,
when you're traveling and when you're,
when you're going places,
you're still,
you're,
you're bringing your world to these other places and influencing it.
When you,
when you go to Starbucks,
when you,
when you get in your house,
you're bringing your world everywhere you go and I don't know how much of what
goes on outside your world really involves you.
There might be a bunch of different parallel worlds intersecting with each other
all the time.
We're just only able to perceive the shit that we consider to be our world.
We're told Deja Vu is our mind thinking of something before it's actually dying.
Like,
like if you go into our room,
your brain actually thinks of something like a micro micro micro second before
you actually think of it.
Instead it feels like Deja Vu.
That's what scientists are saying.
But what if that is something like,
no,
we've been in this simulation before.
We've been in the city with wasting before about last time we died in a fucking
motorcycle accident and this time we're doing it again.
You know,
like it could be this.
There's also the idea is that every thought that you make,
there's this,
this is one of the weirdest theories that I've ever heard about reality.
That every decision you make,
every direction you choose to go and branches you off into a completely separate
area of the universe and it creates an entirely new universe with new
possibilities and new probabilities.
It's like one of the things that he used to say about time travel is you can
never really go back in time because if you did,
you could affect the reality of just by existing in the past,
you could affect the future so much that you might never have been born.
You could,
you could really fuck up the possibilities for everything.
Like you could throw a ripple into the wave.
Well,
the idea is that you,
you sort of do that with every decision you make and every direction you move
in.
And that not only
is that possibility a reality,
but that all the other possibilities are alternate realities that you don't
experience.
But you could have made every wrong choice,
every possible choice and they all branch off into completely new universes and
that all these things are going on together at the same time.
And then when you are having a Deja Vu,
you're almost like criss crossing with your possible worlds and you have like a
blip in the matrix,
a blip.
And yeah,
we just,
we know what we can measure and we know,
we know that when you get in the car and you hit the gas,
you know exactly how fast you go and you look at the speedometer.
But what we don't know is what we're not measuring weird feelings between
people.
You think about someone they call,
there's a weird shit that we don't understand that we don't measure.
And so we kinda like push it under the mattress.
But that shit is tangible.
The feeling that you get when someone doesn't like you.
You know,
like if you ever been around someone,
like,
especially if you around like a girl and her friend doesn't like you and you
don't even have to like say a word,
you just feel it.
Yeah.
You'll feel it.
Go.
What the fuck's going on here?
That that's a real,
that's a real energy being passed back and forth and that can really affect your
life if that person's in your life,
that gross feeling now becomes a part of your reality.
That it actually shapes your possibilities.
I Dunno.
I think,
um,
we're,
we're learning a lot about reality about what you can and can't do to influence
it,
what you can and can't do to shape it.
We are learning a lot about it by doing this fucking show.
We're changing reality.
Brian,
do you know a lot of people,
the realities are being changed because of the show?
They get access to different ideas now.
They don't exist.
I think they do.
I think we don't exist.
How about that?
Oh,
how about that?
How about we,
uh,
we have been created by other people's imaginations to rescue them from South
Dakota.
How about that could be in their world.
You don't exist,
right?
The fuck kind of hippy bullshit is this folks,
this is no way to end a sensible podcast with the great John McAfee on the run
and believes this has been a wonderful experience.
I'm glad you came along with us on this little magical mystery tour.
We will be back tomorrow.
Uh,
it looks like we got to do tomorrow fairly early.
Like noonish with the Great Duncan Trussell.
I got some shit I got to do in the afternoon.
Uh,
so,
uh,
that will be tomorrow's podcast.
And then Thursday the one and only Eddie motherfucking bravo.
And that will also be around the same time,
which is a 12 ish pm Pacific time.
You fucking freaks.
And uh,
both of those will be done with shitty Internet.
So,
uh,
good luck trying to watch it on Ustream,
but we'll have it up on iTunes and we'll eventually get that internet thing
figured out.
Even if I have to call our congressman and I have to get Joe Biden on the phone,
we're going to straighten this out.
If I need to make a donation,
we're going to work it out,
folks.
We're going to keep it together.
We're going to make it grow.
We're all in this freak ride together.
Anything saying,
Brian,
anything to add all these beautiful people out there.
Um,
it's not.
Get Hollywood improv.
December 20th,
American Comedy Club in San Diego,
12,
12.
Okay.
You,
you heard it all there.
You fucks.
And we'll see you.
Brian will be with me and the Great Duncan Trussell this Saturday night in
Austin,
Texas at the Moody Theater.
All right.
You fucks.
Uh,
we love the shit out of you.
We never anticipate any of this happening and we're enjoying every step of the
way.
And,
uh,
we love the fuck out of you and we'll see you soon.
Bye.
Okay.